today I'm excited to introduce you to
Tim also known online as shme150 bought
my first Ferrari and Porsche McLaren 675
LT All in a 12-day period yeah it was
kind of full-on for all of you car
enthusiasts he needs no introduction but
for anybody unfamiliar he is one of the
most incredible car collections valued
at over 10 million dollars his YouTube
channel features some of the most insane
automobiles on the planet and he started
all of this from the humble beginnings
of working a normal nine to five office
job out of college today we're going to
be breaking down the cost of owning an
exotic car collection how you could get
an exotic car collection as well and
also how you could subscribe if you
haven't done that already but first we
gotta thank our sponsor epidemic sound
epidemic sound is the best tool for
creators to soundtrack their content
we've been using epidemic sound for
years now and even though I started
pretty early on using some soundtracks
in the background of my videos I wish I
had started sooner the thing is anytime
you're using sounds or background music
in any of your videos you always have to
fear getting copyright strike driving
your video to monitor eyes the other
struggle that I had is that most of the
free copyright music is just absolutely
terrible and it takes you forever to
search through all the bad ones to find
like the three that work not to mention
there's no guarantee that it's actually
copyright free and when it comes to
viewer retention a good backtrack is
crucial and somehow epidemic managed not
to just have a few but thousands of
copyright free sounds and songs and most
importantly they're really good
epidemics Library offers over 35
000 tracks and 90 000 sound effects so
you'll always have options all tracks
are professionally produced by a diverse
collection of artists and exclusive to
epidemic sounds so you can't get them
anywhere else so click the link down
below so you don't miss out on this
amazing deal and also you get access to
epidemics incredible music catalog again
the link is down below in the
description to get started today and now
with that said let's get back to the
podcast we're not getting back to it
let's get to the podcast welcome back to
the iced coffee hour hi guys I'm shmee
thank you so much for making it all the
way over to Las Vegas absolutely
pleasure yes yeah thank you and you
pulled up in a crazy car you got to see
this car jack it's an AMG GT Black
Series see you know that's a lot of
that's a lot of abbreviations for me
that's like too too too many
abbreviations could you explain to Jack
the significance of this car how many
did they make the AMG GT is kind of
their super Grand tourer Supercar you
could say the GT Black Series is like
the flagship track version so it's the
one that set the record at the
Nurburgring which is often considered to
be the most hardcore race track in the
world and it's not a car that most
people would take on a massive tour
around the United States but we're doing
it so what are you doing where is this
starting what prompted that so I've
always had fun I actually brought my
Ford GT my new Ford GT over here to the
us back in 2019 and I had plans to do
another tour in 2020 and it was so much
fun to explore to go to so many places
to meet so many people to shoot so many
videos the audience was loving it I was
loving it and I always wanted to do it
again but this time we're gone we've
gone kind of completely full-on um so we
started in New York went up towards the
Northeast
um back when it was with all the foliage
she was unbelievably pretty we crossed
over to Toronto and Canada drove all the
way over here we're actually here quite
recently for the SEMA show and then this
is kind of part two we're now going to
California and over towards that side
and then we'll make our way all the way
back across down to Florida and then
we'll go up the East Coast at the end so
it's a big old tour so what's the
purpose of the tour are you just going
around meeting a bunch of different
YouTubers making content and whatnot I
mean so the tagline behind my channel 50
is living the Supercar dream the idea
has always been to create content which
is sharing what I feel exceptionally
lucky to do but I don't think any car
Enthusiast would do if they can you know
the dream Journey the dream road trip so
we go to race tracks we go to car
collections we go for test drives we go
and meet people and it's fun to just
share that passion that so many people
have that speaks through background
genres whatever it is everybody who
loves cars loves cars you talk a
language with that person so it's
basically sharing that almost through
daily updates daily videos as we're on
the road it's a little nerve-wracking to
put so many miles on a million dollar
car I mean driving the car's worth a
million dollars
absolutely prob maybe maybe more
depending on why is your 4GT worth a
million and his is do you have this new
one yeah okay yeah so the new I've done
about 8 000 miles of my 4GT which has
been all around Europe everywhere I've
taken I think on 11 or 12 different race
tracks now I love to drive on track yeah
um but I believe these cars are made to
be driven they're made to be used there
are two different perspectives but
[Laughter]
I think there are two completely
different Avenues right there's either
the investment side and you know in
recent years cars as an investment asset
have been astronomical
um especially kind of limited edition
last of the old school that kind of
thing or even first of the new school
first of the new era I take completely
the opposite idea which is that and I'm
very lucky that I do this as my job as
my business right making videos it's
what grows my my channel
is to use them to the fullest there's no
point in kind of using a car just a
little bit because you just touch on the
surface of what it's like if you go
completely in the mindset of I'm not
worrying not not in the sense that I
want to destroy it but I'm not worrying
on what I'm going to sell this car for
because I plan on keeping it you can
then go into it and say I'm gonna drive
it I'm gonna do this with it because
you're not worrying in the same way yeah
you know some of that though have to do
with the fact that you buy a lot of
these cars at MSRP it works very
differently in Europe so the MSRP system
here and especially in the United States
at the moment the premiums the dealer
markups have been going for we have the
RRP and a dealer can't charge you over
that so explain that in a normal World
rewind three years if you walked in to
buy a fairly normal BMW model you would
be discussing a five thousand ten
thousand pound discount on the retail
price rather than not adding the premium
if that makes sense so another
authorized dealer can't charge you over
RRP
it's still difficult to get an
allocation though sure and it might be
that they want you to buy more of the
regular cars if you want to get the
really special one that kind of thing
okay but it's not that they can say hey
if you want a GT Black Series pay 250
000 over which I think they were running
for here all right so to understand an
allocation because I hear this all the
time in like the watch world as well as
the fancy car world does that mean that
you have to have basically a
relationship with the dealer right like
if you want to go to get a nice watch
you have to buy a bunch of other Rolexes
and stuff like that and like show them
off and get to know the sales person is
it the same with fancy cars like that
it's exactly how it works every brand is
different though like if you take
Ferrari for example they actually have
behind the scenes this point system
where they allocate points to you which
you get for let's say how many cars
you've bought which of their events
you've attended their track events or
their road trip events for going to
their different Gala dinners for going
on there you know internal Ferrari
rallies or whatever it might be so you
get a point system so if you want the
latest and greatest you need to have
whatever X is for that particular car in
your system Porsche a little bit more
hard to read between the lines exactly
what it is because they don't do it like
that it's more on a dealer level but
it's similar to what you just said it's
about having that relationship so if
you're a customer who's who wants to buy
a new GT3 RS that's just launched you
know the latest hot Porsche you probably
need to have a tie cat and a KN and some
regular 911s and have bought a few cars
in the last year or two that's
interesting so what about like the lower
level Porsches or like the lower level
Ferraris is only for like the super
fancy luxury cars that they produce or
is this like can you go in and just buy
a 911 like a base model well in the
current world not really the order queue
is so long that it's not realistic the
an interesting one is the new Ferrari
fuv they call it but the Ferrari SUV
they put a sang way that they've
recently launched because even for that
you need to have a certain other number
of Ferraris in your
history or in your current possession to
be able to get one how many Ferraris it
depends I don't think they publicize
what it is per se but I believe it to be
that you need to effectively own one
current vehicle along the lines of an
sf90 stradale or higher so one of their
kind of Flagship cars we could say plus
another car with a V12 because the new
car is a V12 so you need to own those
two and probably have some points from
some other events and things so that
means you you probably have to buy about
a million dollars for the Ferraris
how much is the SUV yeah to then be able
to spend four or five hundred thousand
four or five hundred grand for that how
many Ferrari pointer do you have
I don't actually I don't know how it
works exactly I I currently have two
cars I've previously owned two cars I
have more than one on order at the
moment so I'm working on it
interesting how did you get started in
all of this have you always had a
background in cars I mean I've always
loved cars
um my YouTube car Journey you could say
began back in January 2010 and I've
uploaded a video on YouTube on average
more than once per day since for 13
years which is kind of crazy and I used
to just run around the center of London
filming cars that went by or I used to
go to big events like the Geneva Motor
Show which is where lots of new products
would be launched the Gumball 3000 which
is one of the world's most famous car
rallies and I would just film a video
and upload it and you remember those
days of YouTube it was
it wasn't ever really with any plan it
certainly wasn't hey one day this could
be a business where I employ a whole
load of people to do really cool stuff
it was I'm just having fun filming cars
and that's kind of evolved from there
what were you doing for work back then I
used to work at an investment
consultancy actually really very
analytical based which I would say is
always where my YouTube side came from
yeah it was like how do I understand
what's happening what's working
publishing content how do you reach
audiences metadata tags analytics you
know the drill it's it's kind of
it's really a thing to try and
understand it Beyond just being creative
and making a nice video how do you find
the time to do both that's a lot of
times especially unless you're just
going like you know on the street here's
a 30 second video just throw up whatever
I was super super lucky actually back at
the start because within the the team I
worked in we were effectively creating a
social media platform within our niche
of the Consulting world and my boss
therefore was super into the social
media world and also very into cars had
owned an early Audi R8 back when they
were new this was you know the same the
same kind of time and effectively saw
what I was doing and I'd started at the
company as one of the first employees
within single digits and the company had
grown to just over 100 by this this
point and he basically allowed me which
sounds bizarre to say to to lower from
working five days a week to working four
days a week because my my things were
taking up to lower to three days a week
eventually before I went full time in
the social media world so it's kind of
can't really repeat that wow but I got
super lucky great guys we still talk the
co-ceos
um still see them both so it's really
really nice actually so did you get a
pay cut yes
okay got it but it was it kind of gave
me the opportunity to take that leap of
faith into it because I think one of the
hardest things when you're growing a
channel you start getting an audience is
that you can earn something maybe you're
only a couple hundred dollars a month
but that's not enough to live on
certainly not in the Supercar world
where you've got to travel to events and
create content around cars you know it's
not cheap whatever you want to do um so
it gave me that opportunity to kind of
Build It Up over a 12 18 month period
rather than going kind of full in which
was amazing like without that it
couldn't be possible how much were you
making back then on the YouTube channel
do you remember not not a lot I think
probably I think at the point I went
full time it was probably in the region
of ten to fifteen thousand dollars a
year that's when you went full time yes
10 to 15 grand how did you how did you
justify it no no that's that's when I
that's when I started let's say
job apologies I shouldn't have used the
phrase full time but at the time also I
was financing an expensive car big
monthly outgoings lived in London right
but as any probably not so sensible
young male does it was that was what you
had to do right what was the car
um my Audi R8 at the time all right okay
yeah so I guess I'd have been 25.
financing the R8 probably all my spare
outgoings each month were going to that
so I couldn't go straight from work into
the YouTube world but
it was that I think draw to the Channel
that I was sharing the experiences of
that car you know the living the
Supercar dream tag I think we were
already using back then and it was very
much taking the audience on road trips
sharing what it's like sharing ups and
downs when things work when they don't
work so it's kind of one of those
gambles that somehow managed to pay off
hold that thought to me because first we
want to thank our sponsor Atlas VPN I've
been traveling a ton recently and I
don't expect it to slow down anytime
soon and with all that traveling come
sketchy and unsecured airport Wi-Fi well
thankfully Jack you use your sponsor
Atlas VPN a VPN stands for a virtual
private Network so essentially whenever
you connect to Wi-Fi you're not
connecting from your computer the one
with all your personal data but from one
of Atlas VPN servers that are spread out
across the world which brings me to my
favorite part about Atlas VPN which is
being able to stream exclusive movies to
certain countries being outside of that
country it's really cool you see most
websites including Netflix and YouTube
will check to see what country you're in
and Blacklist certain videos from other
countries thankfully though all I have
to do is connect to an atlas VPN server
in the US and I can start watching all
my favorite content again yo what are
you watching nothing
they even have special servers that
could support 4K streaming it's also
really easy to use all it takes is one
click and you're connected so I have a
safe new year with Atlas VPN premium you
can protect all your devices in 2023 for
just a dollar seventy a month plus a
30-day money-back guarantee and six free
months upon sign up click the link in
the description to get the New Year's
deal today and now if that said let's
get back to the podcast so how are you
able to expand from the R8 I take it you
quit your job when full time what's your
schedule look like back then because now
you have to just create content around
the R8 and just the car industry in
general yeah so the McLaren happened
while I was at three days a week so at
this point obviously I'd spent okay yeah
growing the channel trying to expand it
and I mean it wasn't something that was
earning
certainly not a hundred thousand dollars
a year or anything like that but it had
reached a point at which that was
possible so I could put the deposit in I
financed the car to be honest I spent
pretty much everything I had at the time
on my McLaren 12C it was the McLaren so
I bought a car in the UK for 125 000
pounds
um which at the time would have been
something like 180 000.
it was really cheap so you have to think
it was still 180 sure but what you have
to remember as well is it's it's funny
because you wouldn't realize it now new
McLarens when they launched and the
first 12 C's were delivered at the end
of I want to say 2012.
um when they started or maybe it was
early 2012 when they started the cars
had a lot of problems they weren't ready
they didn't have an infotainment system
inside that was working full stop didn't
turn on just black screen and it created
a serious depreciation curve for early
cars so my car was had a list price of
225 000 pounds and it was less than a
year old so the previous owner to me had
lost a six-figure sum in 12 months
just not much fun wow so I got an
absolute bug I went on to sell the car
for more than I bought it for as it
happens a year later because the brand
had had a bit of a Resurgence there was
a lot more um
you know people believing in in their
products and they had fixed some of the
problems so they're all running properly
um but it was definitely a big
commitment and there was certainly a
period shortly thereafter where I was
kind of like is this a good idea I just
done something do you remember what your
payment was yeah it was it was roughly a
thousand pounds a month okay which was
fine like I say right it was certainly
I really need this to work I need this
to go somewhere I need this to grow into
something yeah it seems like a common
theme from James doing that with his
Lamborghini and Doug demuro doing that
with his uh Ferrari 360. yes they all
were like I went all in on a car I
bought something I couldn't afford but
it worked out yeah it's it's crazy to
think about it I look back and I'm like
why did I decide that was a good idea
but I think if you've got petrol running
through your veins it's kind of it's
what you want to do it's what you work
but what I certainly felt like I was
working for was to have the opportunity
to drive these kind of cars
um and that drove me every day to get up
and go and do what I could you know to
go and work towards that goal yeah I've
always dreamed as a teenager I was
completely kind of one day I learned a
Supercar that's my goal one day one day
so how old were you when you got the
McLaren uh so early 2014 I would have
been 26. so you're 26 was that like your
daily driver or it was my only call yeah
that was your daily driver
I lived in central London so like even
just like driving to work like what well
we you didn't really drive to work oh
well London has good public transport so
you have we have an underground Network
we have good buses you can walk
everywhere because the city's so small
it's very different to the US I can
imagine you've probably got some pretty
funny looks and stuff like that driving
around like there's always been a big
London car Community even though it
makes absolutely no sense to drive on
the tiny city streets and it's where a
big chunk of my channel began was car
spotting it was filming cars in the city
center
um and going to Sunday morning meetups
which again make no sense why you do
them in central London but you've got to
think of the dense concentration of
wealth and you know property values and
therefore the number of nice cars that
reside in underground garages in the
center of the city I guess it was more
about only driving the car if I was
going out of London somewhere you know
off on a trip I drove the car around
Europe multiple times in that year
um plenty of kind of Adventures and
videos and things but not so much like
not for commuting see that surprises me
because even back then when that was way
bigger of a risk for you to be daily
driving a McLaren right daily driving
like now obviously if you daily drive
like the a million dollar car it's
probably not that scary for you but like
back in the day being 26 having all of
your assets and one thing that you could
be hurtling at like 90 miles an hour
down a freeway it's like like for me I
could not even
fathom that I think I was
very conscious that it was also the
source of Revenue so it was right okay
that means I've always looked at you
know I still have to pinch myself now
big time about the cars that I'm lucky
to own because sometimes it feels like
they're just the means to the business
and then then it's the the waiter second
Moment Like how's that possible
um and certainly back then I just
enjoyed it I enjoyed the engagement with
people whether that was going to events
and meeting people or whether that was
uploading videos and interacting with
comments you know how
cars the sound of cars the feel of cars
just bring out that passion from people
um and you instantly like I said talk
the same language you're instantly
talking to them about something you both
love and when did you fully decide to
quit that job and go into YouTube
full-time it was a period where I had a
couple of big videos in a row so it gave
me something to fall back on or at least
to be able to take the like leap of
faith to go into it so I think summer
2014. what were those videos
a couple of a couple of things all kind
of at the same time but mostly around
the video on my channel that's got the
most views actually which
I'm generally about positivity so I'm
not particularly pleased about this
video video you're talking about as well
that went hyper viral it's a Lamborghini
crashing in London everyone has seen
this video everyone everybody it's that
black vented all right yeah and it's
going down the side street and it hits
like a minivan and then it flips over it
jumps up and yeah you film that you saw
I didn't actually film it but there's
quite a story behind this as well but it
is the biggest video on on my channel
and it's on on YouTube it's done 30
something million views but it's if you
add up everything on Facebook and
Instagram
I remember seeing this on the cover of
like Yahoo yes
but cover I mean front page all the
newspapers everything everywhere but the
interesting story behind it was that at
that time I was actually trying to
approach YouTube a bit more like a
publishing platform as opposed to
exclusively videos that I would make so
I would try and buy rights from people
to use their videos as a lot of people
now do on Facebook and other things if
they're not stealing them that is
because that's pretty Rife but back then
I was trying to to see if I could buy
rights to cool interesting videos and
this actually happened on Mother's Day
so I was out of London with my family
who don't live in the center of London
Science Alpha for Mother's Day lunch and
I heard I had heard there's been a
Lamborghini crash and it's right outside
where I used to live like
half a mile away so so I knew it was
there and I asked a friend of mine if
they could go along and see what's up
you know in the site the side idea was
can you get a video or something yeah
and and he messaged me back later saying
oh somebody I met there had a video of
it
so I was like do you have their contact
info
um anyway he didn't so I put out a post
online saying I've heard there's a video
if anybody knows about that let me know
and somebody sent me a message and
ultimately I bought the video from him
for a couple of thousand uploaded it no
idea at the time that it would be
anything I mean my biggest video to that
date had probably not earned me the
amount of money that I paid him for that
video so it was it was really no idea
yeah no idea but I I kind of believed in
the idea of this or licensing the
content out because I did a lot of
Licensing of the videos I had shot
because I just had a stock library at
this point of so many different cars
that people would buy if they wanted you
know the different TV shows that put
together mashup clips and things that
would want videos of whatever I might
have so I was doing quite a lot of that
and yeah I didn't expect the video to go
so far but it did I remember seeing that
everywhere how do you protect the rights
of your video do people just rip it out
like someone like Yahoo can't they just
link it back to you or I guess then that
they would credit you pretty much
everybody commercial has a department
that deals with this and if you go to
them and say hey you've taken my video
they'll offer you something okay
certainly more in the past than now at
that point it wasn't so much videos of
myself you know presenting everything
now it really is if anybody steals one
of my videos now it's still got my face
in it so it's kind of
I I it's not really worth going after it
depends what it is but at the end of the
day I believe in focusing on doing the
next positive thing rather than starting
some dispute with somebody over sure
even a couple of thousand dollars or it
sounds silly to say but
life is better if you're more positive
about it yeah rather than getting caught
up in silly fights
um at that point there was certainly a
lot more but I guess I felt Super Lucky
and excited that I was able to do
something that I enjoyed so much and
turn it into something that was
generally generating me you know an
income that was the the craziest thing
about it so I didn't really feel
oh this is a problem yeah just you just
let it happen yeah I'm curious what some
of the other videos were that happened
around that same time I think just
basically a few things on the channel
Geneva motor show was always a big one
for new car reveals
um and I was always trying to be the
first to upload videos I would I would
stand at the side of a car reveal you
know holding my camera up over my head
um with a crowd of journalists in front
of me to just try and get that first
clip before I run to a corner at the
motor show Hall where my laptop is sat
on the floor with the sequence ready so
I can just dump in the files and get
them straight on the internet that was
something I would always try and do so
like if you search YouTube for LaFerrari
and you reverse the search I don't think
you can anymore but you could for a time
and find the oldest upload my video of
the LaFerrari reveal at the Geneva motor
show was live before Ferrari's own
pre-filmed video had even gone live like
within 45 minutes the reveal so at the
time it was kind I was going full on to
do whatever I could to get this content
out because 2014 2015 was before the
major magazines and traditional media
Publications had really certainly in the
automotive space had really tried to do
social they weren't they didn't really
know what to do nobody had taken point
on it so it was like this
kind of cheeky opportunity to get in
there before everybody else did with
anything so to share the first content
so I think having time as well was a big
one because it meant I could shoot more
and I started having manufacturers
dealers Private Car collectors reaching
out saying hey would you like to come
and film this would you like to come and
do this so a bit more traveling a bit
more access to things I could only have
dreamed about before no what were you
gonna ask Jack I was gonna ask you so
you bought the video for about two grand
right something like that yeah can you
say how much that specific video you
think generated in Revenue it's very
hard to say and like so this is the
thing that I I said or felt so reluctant
about in terms of it being the largest
viewed video on my channel because
it's what it's brought in over the years
in terms of audience and you can't
really put a value on that you can't put
a metric on that you can say directly
what that video has earned in revenue
and I can tell you it's actually a lot
lower than people would think for 35
million views it's a short video right
it does the average retention is 15
seconds yeah so it's 15 second video
with clicks from around the world it's
not clicks just from you know premium
markets like the us or Europe it's
clicks from everywhere
um so it's certainly a much smaller
figure I can tell you I have videos with
two million views that have earned more
than that video has with 35 million
which I find fascinating there's so much
understanding of how YouTube Works
Beyond I mean preaching to them the the
experts here there's there's so much
more understanding of how this works
than just stick a video online and get
out of many views
um so it's it's what it's really done in
terms of like you instantly know the
video yes so many people know that video
I've had a few videos that have done 10
million plus on more positive things
like the first time filming the Dubai
police cars do you remember have you
seen the Dubai Police Supercar Fleet I
filmed that similar kind of time Audi
R8s and they have well crazy Bugatti
Veyron yeah Aston Martin one seven seven
yeah so they did
I'm just curious because like do they do
the cops actually get in the Veyrons and
like Chase down some dude in like a 98
Civic I didn't actually do that you know
it's really interesting actually it
started completely as a marketing thing
I believe the cars were like the
personal collection of somebody close to
the general of the the Dubai Police or
however exactly it worked
um and they used them at you know for
patrols at Big public events or venues
or that kind of thing
um but it kind of went a bit further and
effectively the most senior officers can
drive and Patrol with them of course
they're not going to be arresting people
because they don't have the right setup
for that but they do use them as police
cars like they are they are there but
you don't think anyone's ever been
detained and thrown the back in the back
of like a Veyron because at that point
and that's what I'd probably break there
is there is a Brabus G-Wagon they could
throw somebody in the back of a privacy
but it's it's it was a you know a huge
marketing thing as so much of the the
content or things you see from the UAE
um have been uh but my my video of
videos of that from the beginning were
obviously really big because people
hadn't seen it before you know I've had
some big videos of first look at a brand
new car that I've managed to push out
from the Geneva Motor Show like I just
said for example and things that I'm
much more proud of of this video as we
could say
wow so why didn't you decide to license
more content or did you and that was
just the one video that happened to do
really well no I did I did
um you know a couple of friends from the
cast spotter World
um actually back then I came up with
agreements that you know they would we
would split the revenue that a video
would generate that kind of thing with
the idea of you know one day maybe that
could be the way the channel runs
sharing the content
being that side of the business which
maybe would have worked quite well it's
hard to say looking back but what I
figured happened was that the audience
were more keen on content that made them
feel like they're related with you so
more personal more talking to them
directly through the video rather than
just
throwing out a video of a car you know
with music over the top or something
yeah it's not quite the same whereas
that personal journey is the way I think
so many people in certainly Myspace but
pretty much across the board with
YouTube have evolved right because
they've created that connection to their
viewers and the viewers follow the whole
journey the crazy thing I think for my
channel is at the beginning I had a BMW
1 series a diesel uh one Series Coupe
lovely car but people can see that
progression from that all the way
through so I now have a garage for about
20 cars and it's all like it's all there
the whole story is there which is really
quite fun let's talk about that a little
bit the journey from the McLaren what
happened after the McLaren I promptly
bought a more practical car that did
happen
um I I upgraded from that McLaren to
another one I actually had four McLarens
in a row
um what I was saying about creating the
content around the brand that there
wasn't really much out there so I had
the 12C I upgraded it to a 650s spider
and then to a 675 LT and that's the
point after the third one that I started
buying other cars and I actually had a
crazy period back in September 2015 and
I remember it so well because in July of
that year was a major algorithm change
major change they introduced effectively
the mid-roll ads that you could add in
on longer videos so massive shift
towards creating longer form content
um and I was like I had my light bulb my
Eureka moment of right I've got to do
this started doing that straight from
the off and for many years that was
actually my most successful month
because I took delivery of the McLaren
675lt but also bought my first Ferrari
and Porsche all in the 12 day period so
it's kind of day yes it was kind of
full-on at the time I was just kind of
what is happening how is this like would
you be comfortable talking about some of
your finances back then to be able to
afford all of these cars because I
remember watching your channel from back
in the early days this was like when you
did the Gumball Rally videos yeah I
still do yeah but but the early ones
this must be been like 2012 or like 2013
and I kind of wondered going through
that like how how do you afford all
these cars yeah I mean I'm the first to
admit around it this is uh I've used a
lot of car finance over the years you
know I very carefully tried to weigh up
what's the right path in terms of
deposits payment plans
um and outgoings and certainly at that
period it was like that the 675 LT
I think I had bought that probably 50 50
and something like that as a deposit the
uh 981 Cayman GT4 my Porsche they were
actually an almost guaranteed overs
straight from the off so I took that on
I think a 50 deposit interest only type
type deal so tiny payments relative but
every limited edition Porsche at that
time was trading for crazy money over so
I suppose my original idea was if I keep
it for six months or 12 months
I'm probably not gonna lose money on it
perhaps a little overconfident but it
did go in that direction so it was fine
and the Ferrari Ferrari Finance actually
do an amazing deal Ferrari prop up their
own cars in a way that no other brand
can can match more in terms of residual
values so they'll give you a four-year
agreement where the it's probably
slightly different from region to region
but they'll give you you know you'll put
in your deposit you'll have your
monthlies but they'll give you a value
at the end you know the the guaranteed
Buy-Back value at the end or the kind of
hand it back value I should say the
balloon payment which will be very very
high but what happens as a result of
that is because pretty much every
Ferrari is financed with Ferrari Finance
is that they have such a good control
over the used market and the values stay
so high so you see this now with newer
cars say the new Ferrari 296 GTB which
is their V6 hybrid is a direct rival to
the McLaren Arturo very similar cars on
paper the Ferrari is probably 70 or 80
000 pounds 100 000 more but the
likelihood is it will probably be worth
more than a hundred thousand dollars
more in two or three years time so even
though it costs more on paper it
probably costs you less to own for three
years
which is really quite interesting so
what is it like to finance a Ferrari
what do they look in terms of how much
money down what a credit score needs to
be what an income requirement I'm so
curious about this so I'm smirking a bit
because
when you say to a finance company back
in 2015 what's your job I earn money
from making videos on the internet they
definitely look at you like
nobody understood that and and certainly
it was quite a I think a hard thing to
do from the outset but you obviously
like anything this you you show them you
demonstrate your income you
give an explanation of what you do and
how you use the cars and let's be real
I'm using the cars for videos the cars
are part of my business activities if
you will as well so parts of the expense
can be written off obviously that's
different in every country and it works
very differently
um so I think at the time I just
submitted the the application
um you know it's been very easy it still
is very easy for lots of people to get
credit on cars obviously maybe not
Ferraris of course but
submitted the application it was
approved and job done put in my deposit
I guess probably 20 25 something like
that okay
and go from there were they hesitant
though about you making content with the
car I heard Ferrari is very particular
about the image because I remember the
thing with David Lee wanting an
allocation I think it was the what was
it the Ferrari answer the convertible or
it was yeah yeah and he didn't get the
allocation and I think he posted
something on Twitter or he posted on
Instagram calling them out on it and
then coming up publicly and saying we
don't like the image or like the flashy
aspect of it I don't think it was so
much that and like without wanting to go
too specifically into David's situation
it's the point system
the majority of I believe his collection
of cars had come from third-party
sources because he had bought amazing
cars like absolutely amazing cars but to
buy a laferrariapater you need to have
your 20 cars that you've bought direct
from Ferrari it's a very different
system they are incredibly protective of
the brand vastly more than anybody else
I have a close relationship with them
and I love working with Ferrari they
make amazing cars but they can be
sometimes you have you have to be very
like play by their rules if you want to
you know be able to work with them it's
one I think that if you are you know in
that Ferrari World you kind of know that
kind of respect that you know the
history that they have and the the
people who are buying Ferraris they are
the you know the ultra VIPs of the world
kind of thing you know to be building
and buying LaFerrari apertures I can't
only made 200 of them right it was two
million dollars each
yeah yeah I mean it'd be double that if
not more right now I heard also that now
with the newer Ferraris they have some
sort of system where they could tell if
you've changed the exhaust or if you
modify the engine in such a way where it
like Flags it avoids the warranty is
that true it's pretty much true with
every company
um like when the new Corvette came out
the C8 generation called that a lot of
buyers were quite unhappy that Chevrolet
had completely locked it out so you
couldn't modify you had to put kind of
piggyback ecus if you want to change
anything BMW do a big job of it if
you've changed anything on a BMW it's
logged in the system on any new car and
that will be there forever you know even
if you revert your changes to sell it
the dealer will scan it and it will say
yeah this happened
like a lot of these new cars are
completely locked down that's crazy yeah
it makes it really difficult so for
example the two Ferraris I currently own
are completely bone stock unchanged
because
I don't want to get into any warranty
battles if something goes wrong that
they're known you know they want they're
very happy for you to use the cars you
know it's not like they don't want you
to go and track them and drive them and
do some miles with them but they don't
want you to stick aftermarket parts on
them because it's not the image
it's not the right the right look now
why do you think it is that Lamborghini
doesn't go after
uh modifications as much as other
companies do I think it's the brand
image of Lamborghini they are rebellious
right sure if you buy a Lamborghini you
are a flamboyant character you want to
be out there you're that kind of person
you know if you look at cars that are
driving down in South Beach Miami or you
know through Dubai or something the
things you see the most over Lambos if
you go and rent a Supercar you rent a
Lambo right it's that kind of thing
because
there's nothing that says yeah this is a
crazy experience more
like there's there's no alternative so I
think Lamborghini embraced that they
know their customers are these kind of
people like if you go to a Lamborghini
event if you go to a Ferrari event
people will be very formal in their
suits yeah they're dressed up you go to
a Lamborghini event people are just in
shorts and t-shirts right yeah it's a
completely different type of buyer and
you actually see that big Ferrari
collectors tend not to own a Lamborghini
and big Lamborghini collectors will not
own a Ferrari and it's amazing that you
have that complete divide between the
two Brands whereas like a McLaren
collector will probably have some
Porsches because those two cars are very
track focused and kind of line up with
one another right so you see I see these
kind of Trends all over the place but
people who have multiple Lamborghini
serial Lamborghini buyers they're not
Ferrari guys huh what car make do you
think is
is uh is liked too much is overhyped
interesting what you want to spot here
yeah I'm very on the spot with that one
what I'm careful what you said I already
is listening you know what if we talked
about let's say the multi-million dollar
cars you know this world of Bugatti
Koenigsegg Pagani what's really
interesting in that space is how all of
these cars are beyond what any of us
need in terms of performance what they
can do art pieces even but they all do
this quite differently like it's really
hard to compare even those kind of cars
because they're not the same thing if
you then come down to the Supercar field
Ferrari Lamborghini McLaren Porsche
again every car these companies produce
now is Way Beyond what any normal driver
can use can do you know if you buy a
seven eight nine hundred thousand
horsepower car we're normal humans the
the rate of acceleration and cornering
ability you can't do on the road like
these cars make absolutely no sense
um so again it comes much more down to a
person's emotional connection with a
particular car and while one person
might be much more in the camp of a
Porsche because they're bulletproof and
they can do endless track miles for
example I prefer a little bit more
emotion out of a car you know I prefer
the flare of an Italian engine more than
that for example so
I don't necessarily think
well I couldn't I couldn't really point
one brand and say you know they're over
hyped per se
but I think different cars will appeal
to different people you're like I'm I'm
more of a McLaren and a Ferrari guy than
I am a Porsche guy so for you personally
Porsche I I'm not I'm not the biggest
Porsche guy um I've owned a couple
um I've had a GT3 two gt4s um recently
had a taikan their electric car
um but like I'm not the one lining up at
the door for a new GT3 RS or whatnot
because I find the brand quite difficult
as well they're quite like what we're
talking about with the allocations it's
impossible to know what you need to do
like if somebody said to me you can have
a GT3 RS if you buy these three cars
will sign the contract now done then you
can think about it but I don't like
having to buy this this this this this
to maybe get that I think some of that
spoils the mystery though because if
Ferrari did that let's just say and said
okay you need to buy these four cars and
you'll get this then it then it's like
any rich guy can say all right now I'm
gonna buy this for all right shove them
off to the set I'll buy that but keeping
some of the mystery and having someone
at Ferrari hand select those people I
think is part of what makes people want
to go the extra mile like maybe I should
buy that fifth row just to get on their
good side maybe I should shake these
hands over here go to that event it's
not required but let me do it anyway
because it really proves that you want
it that badly no it's true and you know
a lot of the brands are Keen to keep
their biggest supporters close I think
that's the same with any industry not
exclusive to cars you know people who
genuinely buy the cars use the cars and
sing the Praises of those cars to their
Social Circle to their you know audience
online or whatever it might be those are
people that the brand want to keep a
hold of and you know some Brands
actually do
a pretty good job of that
um I think it's quite a hard thing
because as soon as somebody gets too
close to the brand then you've got a
difficult relationship that grows and
I've I've been there with the stuff I've
done over the years obviously because
and I've made videos that have had a
whole lot of views about all of these
different things and very aware that
sometimes the manufacturers are watching
over my back yeah and you know you want
to keep that relationship as well so
swing some roundabouts how do you
balance the two between making content
and being honest about your experience
with the car versus not upsetting the
dealership or the brand it's actually
really difficult it's really really
difficult because you know as soon as
something goes wrong with a car
obviously the brand don't want you to
talk about it obviously
um but then if you don't talk about it
and all of a sudden like a car is not in
my garage for some reason or I'm not
driving a car for some reason my
audience are like where is it why is it
why are you not telling us why is this
what's the secret you know so you're
then not being honest with your audience
and that's the most important thing you
have as a content creator is your
honesty to your audience because
they are what make makes it possible to
do what you're doing yeah
um
I try and give the brand a very fair
opportunity to help with whatever it is
not not like trying to pull strings of
if you don't do this I'm gonna go and
shout and make a video about it but in a
kind of you know please help me my car's
got an issue
you know I need to use it for an event
next week is there anything you can do
yeah that kind of thing and to be fair
most genuinely are but you've built
you've got to remember you've built a
relationship at this point with your
sales team and your service team so
you're not kind of calling up somebody
you've never spoken to before saying fix
my car type thing
um I mean I've just had a recent bit
that's been really frustrating to be
honest my McLaren Senna needed two new
dampers Parts almost impossible to get
across the board right now
um and it took probably six months to
get them in so for six months I couldn't
drive the car what what was the part
dampers suspension possible suspension
um crazy expensive Parts as it happens
but just you know unobtainium
um and so there was a lot of back and
forth as you can imagine
um but ultimately you know they helped
they tried to get them the dealership
have been great good communication about
it also
you know I'm not about to go make a
video of screaming and shouting and
saying the service is awful because I
understand the global situation you know
this is a the fact that I can't get
parts for my silly unnecessary car is a
very small concern considering
everything else you know around the
world I'm sure now how much of that
though is you having a channel and a
large presence that they put you at the
priority oh you think you would get the
same experience as someone else who has
no following whatsoever calls in my sin
is broken
um I don't try to use it like that
though
um
I know that when various cars I own
whether it's Ferraris my Ford GT or
Lambos or whatever go for a service
they'd probably have an extra look over
them beyond what they might otherwise do
because at the end of the day it's not
good for anyone if the car goes wrong on
a video it's not good well maybe it'll
get more views but right it's for you
yeah it's not good in theory
um if something goes wrong
um so I'm 100 sure that brands have done
that along the way one interesting thing
people often ask me about though is does
having a social media platform mean you
can get cars that you wouldn't otherwise
get allocations for and generally I
believe the answer to that is no and the
reason because the reason I say that is
because they need to be showing the
example of what you need to do so
Ferrari can't just give me a new 812
competency only their new limited
edition V12
um GT car because I don't have five
Ferraris in my garage so the next person
who has the same two cars I have goes
along and says hey why didn't I get one
so I think that kind of is a swings and
roundabouts thing as well it's sometimes
in your favor sometimes against your
favor
like I say I don't I've never you know
gone in saying you've got to do this for
me because otherwise I'm gonna do that
or whatever because I don't I don't
believe in that I think if you do the
right thing for people they'll do the
right thing for you in this respect in
in life in general and it's the same
with you know upgrades or services or
things I don't reach out to everywhere I
go saying hey can I have this for free
yeah I know there are plenty of people
that do I believe that if you want
service book in do what you know
purchase book whatever you need and hey
if they appreciate what you do for them
they might give you a kickback from it
or give you something off so I've always
worked with that and now I have some
great partners and things that I work
with as well so it's you know it's
worked out all right so what do you have
in your garage right now oh gosh they're
gonna be a long full list yeah I want
the full list I'm not even sure if I can
do the full list from from craziest down
shall we say my craziest car is a Zenvo
a Zenvo tsrs and most people don't know
what it's envo I don't even I don't know
I know what that is and I I love cars
yeah so so Zenvo is a Danish company
um the car has 1 360 horsepower
um in-house engine full carbon
everything as you can imagine brutal
thing to drive I kind of describe it as
an Aventador on steroids it's really
aggressive
um
I'm gonna pick this up a couple of
months ago how much did that cost that's
fairly expensive wow crazy machine this
this is real yeah oh my gosh look at
that it actually kind of reminds me of
my Miata
very similar oh my God yeah it's it's a
wild wild thing
um very small company how many cars like
have they made they make a couple a year
a couple a year yeah how did you get one
so I've I've known the company for a
long time I've worked with them I think
I made my first video with them back in
2000 oh yeah there you are you typed in
the car and yeah so that's mine is the
purple one if you've seen any pictures
of that popping up wow if you look up
Zenvo and see a purple one it's yours
yeah it will come up because it's it's
all over the Internet oh my gosh but now
like I say I've known the founder of the
company
um okay for nearly a decade now I filmed
so many videos with them and they
recently hired a few they've done a big
hiring drive and they've hired a lot of
people that I've worked with before
um from other uh Automotive oems so they
kind of assembled this dream team and
they have some really exciting stuff in
the future so we chatted for a long time
as you can imagine because you don't
just buy a car like that on a whim
um for me there was a lot of am I Really
Gonna Do this that's that's I was making
financing though yeah that's that's a
big part of financing they helped
introduce me to somebody who can help me
with that I mean don't get me wrong the
deposit yeah you have to put in like a
sizeable double-digit deposit of a
multi-million dollar car it's it's a
scary number whatever you do
um but I believe in what they're doing
in the future and it's really exciting
like they gave me opportunities to come
and be at the factory and lay some of
the pre-preg carbon fiber so before it's
hardened to make the wheels on my car
full Carbon wheels they're way lighter
than any metal wheel or anything and I
got to be part of that like I signed
some parts of it that are now on the car
that I drive around
um same with the interior and just I
went back to the factory probably six
seven eight times through the build
process to go and see it and then
obviously we're now taking it to some
really cool events it might well be over
here next year that's the plan I would
like to see it now I'm curious we'll
pause there how is that car as an Roi
for the channel because I remember James
stradman talking about his Bugatti
saying it's a loss leader like that will
lose money in the channel but it gets
more people in and maybe I could make it
up on the back end so it is exactly that
yeah mixed with the personal excitement
okay there is no bottom line that can
possibly make sense purchasing a car
like that because the amount of views
you would need or or whatnot is just not
feasible and obviously it's also very
unknown you know when I sell that car
whether it's in three years or ten years
I couldn't tell you now I have no idea
what this is about to say I don't know
if it'll have lost 50 or gained 300 you
know I I I've got no idea how long's a
piece of string because it's such a
small boutique brand there's nothing to
look at there are no like sales figures
for cars being sold because the only
people who bought them still have them
it's exactly what James said a bit of a
lost leader into the channel in the
sense of
how crazy is this content and you know
the the views on on the car in some ways
aren't as big as if I had bought a more
well-known car of that price point and
if I had bought a Bugatti the views
would be bigger for sure because more
people are looking for Bugatti content
and more people instantly know what a
Bugatti is you know as envo we're
talking about you've not heard of them
before I believe in their future though
and I find that really interesting I
think when in five six seven ten years
time people are looking for zembo
Content they'll end up looking at my
videos and it will keep everything very
current
um so I think I'm playing a much longer
game with it but then I'm a car guy at
the end of the day how cool is it to
have built parts of my own hyper car
that I'm not going to travel around the
world that will put you over the edge
there versus like a Pagani or a
Koenigsegg price is relevant price is
relevant the zembo is a cheaper entry
point
um the tsrs My particular model
um here in the US suspect the car would
be about two million dollars whereas a
Pagani or a Koenigsegg you'll be looking
at three or four so that is relevant I'm
not gonna lie I'm sure if you know if
you have billions in the bank it makes
no difference but I'm certainly at the
point where an extra million dollars is
something that I can't just go and no um
go and go and drop
um so that's certainly a point but also
the closeness with the company and the
excitement of feeling that I can do
something really cool getting the name
out there getting the brand name out
there you know I know multiple people
are now buying the cars who've seen my
videos like how cool is it yeah as as
nonsensical as it sounds how cool is it
that I can upload videos of
two million dollar car and people will
see those videos and go and buy it you
know it's like you think you've got a
wild audience yeah you think if you
think imagine that you think of
influencing for selling accessories or
selling like you know easily attainable
things but it is genuinely true even
with Hyper cars you know you're bringing
to attention something that a product
that people didn't know about
um and one of the coolest things I
always find is the number of people who
have that you know who have that
opportunity in life to buy these kind of
cars of following some of the content I
create kind of like is this real that's
very cool yeah it's really really cool
but it showcases what it's all about you
know there are some amazing engineers
and technicians and designers and people
behind the brand at zenfo and that's
what I love going there and just talking
to people the people who are working on
the wheels on the engine in the Paint
Shop talking to them about what they do
and their passion for the brand and at
the end of the day it's kind of
supporting also this whole well the
economy of it right you're buying the
car you're keeping you're giving the
opportunity for these people to be able
to go on and make even better products
which at the end of the day is amazing
really isn't it to be honest so click
the link in the description to uh today
yeah he's our affiliate the first five
people who buy his envelope get a free
auto t-shirt t-shirt I've actually
influenced people to buy Lexar cards you
know like because they sponsored me on
the channel but I can't imagine it's
getting somebody to buy a two million
dollar car that I don't think you know
it's not that simple somebody doesn't
watch a video right no no no no no but
that's where it starts
now yeah we joke yeah but I assure you
it's happened yeah I have filmed cars on
my channel before
or even walked around a showroom with
cars in the background I'll upload the
video and I'll get a call the next day
from the salesman being like thanks for
the video somebody just saw that car on
your video and has bought it about
expensive cars you know we're talking
six figure cars it's it's crazy to me
that that happens but it does happen you
know what's neat uh I haven't talked
about this in a long time when I posted
my 78 Tesla video yes I put my Tesla
referral link as the first link in the
description guess how many Teslas I sold
I can imagine it's a lot let's guess how
many views does the video have uh
probably 8 million
fifteen thousand I'm gonna guess no 280.
oh you're really close uh about 240.
240. I was I was going way over because
people click the link and paste the
deposit there right no this is actually
a Tesla is actually uh delivered okay so
if someone places a deposit it shows us
pending until they actually take
delivery of the car so think about that
240 people have genuinely
watch the video and click the link that
doesn't mean I mean I reckon probably 15
000 people have bought cars who have
watched your video and maybe used
another Lane yes or just gone direct to
the website yeah rather or already had
one on order or were just aware of it
you know
um actually probably way more than that
Tesla owners have watched your video
that's the crazy thing I mean I've
watched a video I'm not a Tesla owner
but I've watched the videos yeah
um it's amazing to think isn't it yeah
because that's the deposit is well the
car isn't cheap it's 40 50 60 70 000.
yeah and the cool part now is that I
have basically unlimited supercharging
miles uh just because of people signing
up through that link so they
Unfortunately they changed it
um I got the car right after they
expired the uh the referral program
where I think it if you referred a
hundred people you got a free Tesla
Roadster so I would have gotten two free
Tesla roadsters
from that one video but they expired it
so now it was like every person that
signs up I think you get 5000 free miles
of supercharging
yeah but you get 204 I mean I'll never
be able to drive the car as many miles
as I have but the downside is that they
ended up putting a limit on it so I had
basically almost a million miles of free
supercharging and then now they say it
expires in 2024. all of it oh no yeah
so if elon's listening right now we need
to change it back they also used to do a
giveaway so uh every time you referred
somebody you would be entered for a
monthly giveaway to win a model y or a
Tesla Roadster to my knowledge I don't
know anybody that's one or the I don't
think they ever did it I think they just
said it and because I tried doing a lot
of research on this could not find one
verified winner
interesting but it's there I mean I've
got the emails I've screenshots of like
hey this is their new plan nothing
silence interesting so I think they
figured they could just get away with
not doing it and no one's gonna say
anything I mean it's just like the
YouTubers that give away like
PlayStation 4s and stuff like that like
the kids YouTubers the iPhones
it's actually really hard to give away
stuff online because you end up getting
a winner you reach out to them and they
don't reply you have to go down the list
until you get somebody who does but it's
also doing that legally yeah because uh
oh gosh there was something that that I
looked into a while back because I
wanted to give away free stocks yeah but
to do that there had to be a way to
enter without any commitment through
like a sweepstakes yeah well it's got to
be no purchase necessary yeah but it's
also gotta be like there's all these
limits if you want to do it to the book
so no purchase necessary it's got to be
one there's got to be a free place to
end it's like it became such a big
hassle that it was easier just not to
give away stocks like unfortunately kind
of but you you want to make sure it's
done correctly but yeah makes sense
there's an entire Theory oh my gosh I
know what's happening with my voice
there's an entire Theory maybe age
difference here is a little you know
maybe you guys won't get this but it's
huge on YouTube uh there was a show that
Jack and I probably watched called a
Suite Life of Zach and Cody that was on
Disney Channel and they ran the
sweepstakes that you bought this yogurt
like Danimals yogurt and they were
giving away uh like a vacation or
something with the the stars and there's
so many people who have made YouTube
videos like
saying well who won because nobody won
and then this guy came out and said he
won but then they linked it to like
another sweepstakes so really it's been
this mystery for like over whatever 10
years now can't trust it no I can't
trust the world no but when you when you
were doing the referral links to the
tessas and same with many other uh
crazes on the platform I was watching
that thinking I want to get involved
with this because I was thinking I could
do that but Tessa hadn't yet reached
Europe in the same way oh so I had to
watch John in jealousy because I was
thinking if I bought an early one and
made videos
that could be a business Avenue right
yeah you know what's crazy in the
beginning Tesla videos were similar to
the videos that you'd make on an iPhone
and people would love them I'm still I'm
sure to this day they would if I were to
make more Tesla videos but some of my
most viewed videos now on the channel
are Tesla like model 3 reviews yeah like
my favorite things about the Tesla the
worst thing about the Tesla here's how
it is after a year I think it's yeah
it's it's twofold right there's there's
so much Intrigue in the electric car
World positive and negative
um the products themselves and Tessa's
such a talking point controversy
overload right
with every possible thing I I bought my
taikan well probably two years ago now
as an experiment because I thought
Porsche electric car let's try this
online and the videos I shot with that
were huge as well
um not Tesla level huge but relatively
let's say buying a Panamera the
combustion engine equivalent they all
flew ad rates were super high loads of
interest in how the charging network
works and that kind of stuff and that
kind of series you could say return on
investment of that car was very positive
at the end of the day that worked really
well that's good I got a couple of more
questions for the Zenvo how long did it
take to to make the car
so from startup construction to delivery
probably 15 months that kind of thing to
make I mean you've got to think it's a
small company so and they make
everything in-house everything that's
not bad engine actually gearbox
every carbon part everything
starts like buying one yeah
yeah
I can only do 12. and I'm guessing they
don't just like sell that to anybody
right like do you have to have
connections with because you said they
only sell what a coupling no I I mean
like let's let's say you called them up
and said can I buy one and they don't
know who you are they're going to be
like come and meet us and you know come
along to an event where we are with the
car that kind of thing because obviously
they want to know that you're a real
person right really buying the car
um Beyond just putting in a big deposit
um I think a lot of people in that world
are connected to somebody very few
people who buy a seven-figure car
wouldn't be known by the company already
or by one of the employees or one of
their customers you know for example if
somebody reached out to them
they it might
it's probable that somebody who works
there knows who that person is there's a
very it's a very small world at that end
of the the hypercar game shall we say do
you know if the company is profitable
I know that they're putting a lot of
money into investment at the moment for
future product which is one of the
reasons why I got involved because
they're developing some really cool
stuff so I think you should just take
ownership in some of the company
I'm not sure I could afford it
still they could give you five percent
I'm gonna say they you deserve five
percent selling it really well here yeah
but you never know you never know hey I
think at the end of the day this is one
of the things we were talking about
right my goal is to to help promote the
company and I've bought the car it's not
like they've given me the car or
something they are looking after me with
the car so they'll send a flying doctor
to me if the car needs some some help or
something
um they'll take it to a few events
around the world which is super cool
because I get to turn up on my cars
there right so this is one of the really
exciting parts of the whole process but
what I love is you know if I can bring
them actual business and be part of the
company growing and I'm sitting here
hoping that they'll let me be part of
that as it happens you know future
products future opportunities because at
the end of the day you know when they
released the new car one of the perks
for me is if I'm the person who's able
to film it first because at the end of
the day that will get loads of traffic
on my channel help grow some extra
audience bring in the revenue associated
with the video there's more to it but in
the normal World wouldn't be relevant
you know what I mean just from the extra
business I haven't actually come off
that
so you got the Zenvo what's next oh yeah
it took a long time to get through the
center didn't we go through these cars
yeah so Zenvo tsrs McLaren Center and
Ford GT we mentioned all right let's
let's start with the Santa how did you
get that allocation for Santa that was
really difficult actually that was that
was hard so I'd had the 12C the 650 675
Coupe and then the spider
um but basically McLaren wanted you to
have owned either
a sports series car which was the 570s
basically or the uh new Super Series car
which was the 720s Now new 720 s's were
riddled with problems early cars were
really difficult for their customers
right
without going too much into it just
problem after problem after problem so I
had said you know I don't really want
one yet you know I might get one down
the line but I'm not going to buy one
until they work because I didn't want to
sell my 675 my previous car which I
still to this day own six and a half
years on I think it's one of the
greatest cars McLaren I've ever made so
I'd put my name in for the center and
I'd put my name in two years before they
revealed it probably one of the first
people as soon as I got wind of the code
name of the project coming along and
what it was going to be a track focused
you know it's it's not as hyper hyper as
December and other things but it was the
best part of a million dollars of car
um so I was super keen on it but my
initial application got declined so even
though I'd been talking to them about it
for ages prior to reveal
um I actually got turned down for
getting the car I was a bit like you
know but disappointed I was like I've
owned four cars from a company that's
only seven years old is that like a what
is it like an email like a college
rejection letter no it was more just I
mean I had a relationship with my
salesperson at the dealership it was
more just casual conversation and they
just said hey sorry I think it was more
we were chatting on a regular basis so
it wasn't
yeah it was more like I'm not sure if I
can get you one kind of thing okay
gradually and then it was like I started
hearing that other people who got them
and I didn't have one yet and I was like
you know bummed out about it I was like
come on I've been singing this company's
Praises for years on YouTube McLaren is
my local manufacturer they're like 20
miles away from where I live so it's
kind of like
what what you know what did I do wrong
type thing um and then as it happens I
actually was at
um I used to go to I still do obviously
go to the events they run the customer
track days for example and I was at the
track there at spa and a lot of the
senior staff go to those kind of events
because that's where they always have
their VIP customers generally you know
you've paid a lot of money to go to
these kind of days so you get some
exclusive track time
um and a lot of the people who own p1s
or McLaren race cars would go to that
kind of day
um and I was having a casual chat with
um a friend who's very well connected uh
with McLaren and he kind of went over to
the CEO who was there and said you know
is there any possibility he's here and
he came over and we had a chat and
managed to make things work which was
something they did intentionally
um the board and CEO level with the
center allocations did have I think 100
and 500 cars themselves that they could
choose who they go to be on the standard
dealer Network process and I think you
know at the end of the day I've done
what McLaren would have wanted me to do
with the car I've had it on track
probably four or five times I've done
four thousand miles with my car I still
own it you know some people stick them
for sale the day they take delivery and
I'm not going to sell mine anytime soon
so so what could you do like
hypothetically if you take delivery of
the McLaren and then sell it immediately
afterwards it's like blacklisted right
yeah I never give you a car again supply
and demand with these things you know
some cars values the day you can take
delivery will be massively over and some
just simply won't
um I think it comes down to the
manufacturer if you flipped a Ferrari
you are gone good luck they will not
talk to you after you get this new 812
competency only and you flip it
overnight and they figure that you
flipped it overnight because obviously
some people do and we'll buy it in a
company name and try and disguise that
right
um if you do flip it you will not be
buying another Ferrari so hypothetical
numbers that's center right yeah like
immediately once you bought it how much
could you have flipped it for in the US
market they were much stronger than in
the UK market so initially a little bit
um I think initially in the US maybe 300
000 over so a car a spect car would have
cost you around 1 to 1.1 million and you
could sell it for 300 000 over that kind
of thing
um they did soften there was a period
where they probably dropped down to I'm
guessing here but 800 000 dish where
there's an alien did they only go down
to a million they're back over a million
again now
um you know you see these curves
obviously depending on availability of
credit what the markets are like etc etc
but also what the demand is like and
with the kind of in our face electric
future that is being talked about
non-stop cars with combustion engines
are in so much Demand right now like
people just want to enjoy them or they
still can so anything from recent years
that's in limited numbers the values
have just been flying so I believe the
center is one for the future because I
believe it's one of the fastest cars
that will ever be made without
electrical assistance how fast is it lap
record times
um of anywhere it goes basically a new
genre genre of cars have arrived now the
hybrid the hyper cars the likes of the
Mercedes amg-1 the Aston Martin Valkyrie
cars that have even more power and will
set even faster lap times but that's
what I mean about the lack of any
electrical motors also it makes it more
fun to drive because you're not lugging
so much weight around the track
um really hard to give any kind of
meaningful numbers
but if say if the Santa went to the
Nurburgring in Germany it would be like
up there it would be black record time
fast it it's hard to put a specific on
it because McLaren don't want that image
they don't actually do it interesting
yeah some customers have done it with
their cars and gone to Silverstone and
gone to Spa Franco Shaw and gone to you
know big circuits and broken records
there's a video topic right there Graham
how you can make 300 000 overnight well
speaking of that we got to talk about
the Ford GT because that is something I
would I would have loved an allocation
to that but I think I think they're all
sold out they've all been spoken for
yeah they're about to finish the build
it's been a long time yeah
um I went to the introduction of the car
at the Detroit Auto Show in January
2015. wow that's crazy to think about
the first customer car was delivered in
the last few days of 2016. which may or
may not have something to do with
homologation requirements for the Le
Mans win that year that you have to
deliver a customer car in the same year
I believe but ultimately they've been in
production since somewhere in 2017
through to early 2023 six years so what
was your application process like did
you have the original Ford GT no so I
never had an original Ford GT and truth
be told I didn't own a Ford before the
GT
um before I got the allocation for the
GT
um I went to that launch event so I was
going to all the motor shows
um and pretty much from day one I was
like trying to talk to everybody I could
I was like I need one of these we
thought it would be a 300 000 car when
it was released it ended up being a lot
more than that especially in the UK
um but even that day I was like running
around trying to speak to everybody you
know all the heads of PR marketing
eventually like really senior people at
Ford and multimatic who were responsible
for the car so I was in Detroit for
three days so I was at the show stand
the whole day like all day every day
around the Ford team and then went back
home and I actually walked into a dealer
when I got back home a Ford dealer in
London and just said hey can I order one
of these and they were like I've never
seen that before that's got to be some
kind of weird concept yeah they had no
idea what it was but of course why why
would they I wasn't in any Ford system
and Ford I don't know if you know this
they kind of developed it like a Skunk
Works project in the basement in Detroit
it wasn't it was other than the 20 or 30
people working on it nobody knew about
it really it was completely secret until
they did that apple one one more thing
style reveal at the show they had been
showing the new Shelby GT350 the new
Raptor and then boom we've got one more
thing to show you for GT rolls out and
the whole crowd is just like all struck
because I mean I I had heard a rumor but
I think only like a week before it was
really quiet it's like massive kudos to
them for achieving that
um but fast forward nothing really
happened I I went to a whole lot of
events trying to figure like how do I
get one of these like how does this work
they'd said from day one it was only
going to be about they said four and a
half years of production 250 cars a year
so roughly 1100 1200 cars which is about
what it is but just over a longer period
because it took longer to ramp up the
production so I was like it's clearly
going to be like diamond dust you know
how does this work so I went in June
2015 to Le Moore the Le Mans 24 hours
where they introduced their race car and
announced that they were going to race
the next year
um so I was like you know again talking
to everybody trying to figure everything
out I went to all the shows I went to so
many events to try and understand it
then fast forward to April 2016 and they
announced that it was going to be this
application process this form you would
fill in where you would talk about what
commercial types you have with Ford you
know you're a part supplier or a big
customer or something what your racing
experience is what events you partake in
what different series your car ownership
and they did ask about your social media
presence and that was widely documented
at the time like they're going to give
all of these to influencers and you know
nobody else is going to get one and I
found this really really really
interesting because obviously I
submitted my application I did it on day
one and you could add a 60 second video
to your application and this was only
for the first 500 cars two or three
years later they would then do the rest
of the cars
um and obviously in the first time
around you got to think this is back in
2016 most people don't go out and make a
video to apply for a car but obviously
being a video guy I did and I it created
something that basically snapped into 60
seconds why I thought I just why I
thought I'd be a good customer for the
car and what I could do with the car and
what I do with my current cars so I
showed like driving my McLaren at spa
and I showed going to a big event with a
massive crowd in my Ferrari in Italy and
I showed just doing all sorts of
different car stuff
um you know voice over Style on a video
um that I actually filmed because I was
in Monaco at the time so I woke up and
went and just made the video straight
away same day because in case there was
any like priority for doing it faster or
something I was like I've got to get
this in today day one
um and you know you didn't hear anything
until a couple of months later
um when they sent out emails basically
letting you know either you had secured
an allocation or you're on the wait list
for the later cars or you weren't able
to get one and they announced for that
first 500 cars that they had six and a
half thousand completed legitimate
applications so six and a half thousand
people who would were in a position to
buy that car which is crazy and um you
know my email had come through like I
say saying that I secured an allocation
and I was like amazing believe this at
the time I was well I was ecstatic and
excited but I was like oh my gosh how am
I gonna afford this because that was
double the price of any car yeah like I
had my McLarens but the UK price of the
car was 600 000 pounds oh because it's
us price plus all the import duties and
tax is in conversion is that before
options is that like there wasn't much
you could add so 600 was about where it
ended up with options it's a bit more
now for the later cars
um so I didn't really know how I'd got
the application allocation I knew that
the team from Ford Great Britain had
been championing for me to get one
um they were being amazing like they
were super Keen but I mean I was going
to all of the events and things with
them and covering all four products and
you know I was telling them that I'd
take this car around the world and I'd
do a ton of cool stuff with it what
transpired down the line actually
because not very many people in the
social media world did get an allocation
like a lot of people had applied for one
as a you know maybe but very few people
did get one I mean like I was shocked
that James didn't get one because he had
the G the normal 4GT well the 2005 or
six I don't think he had it back then
I think
his situation was actually a little bit
more complicated around it
um but for me you know I was just
thank my lucky stars like how crazy is
this this is so cool
um blessing in disguise because like I
say I had to then start working out how
to afford it when I'd eventually get it
and there was no information about when
it would arrive and what the story would
be so how did it work did you have to
pay for the car up front or you had to
when it went into build to give a 50
cash deposit up front Okay this is a lot
of money
um
what was quite interesting prior uh to
getting to that stage though was was I
did kind of find out more about how I
had managed to get one because there
were only I think 12 UK cars in the
first batch so in that first 500 cars
like really lucky to get one and mine
was the last mine was actually the last
European car of the first
lot so number 80 of 80 of the European
cars which is kind of cool to this day
but what I was told at a later time was
that the way I got my allocation was
actually that they chose 10 out of all
the allocate applications that had
videos so they picked 10 of the
applications that had a video
to choose the cars and mine was one of
those so it wasn't having a social media
following per se it was that my 60
second video actually stood out which is
really cool it made all of that stress
that day worthwhile I am shocked by the
way I look at bring a trailer just about
every day yeah the number of cars the
four GTS that are being sold right now
with zero miles yeah they're almost all
completely undriven a lot of them have
still the plastic on the car the the
protection over the seats maybe like
with this 20 to 80 miles so too many
people sat on them but this is It's
really interesting why this is so Ford
tried to avoid people who have garages
full of many of these cars they wanted
you to really appreciate your Ford GT
you know if you own 20 Ferraris you're
not the guy for them they wanted you to
be someone who has a couple of nice cars
but this is going to be a car you're
going to treasure and you're going to
look after and you're going to really
love owning
what happened off the back of that was
all of a sudden because people who have
a lot of money to buy whatever they want
can't get one the prices overnight hit
like two million dollars so the US cars
500 000 or 550 with spec were suddenly
selling or being demanded at two million
dollars so your next customers for whom
this is the most expensive car they've
ever bought are looking at a car that
potentially has one and a half million
dollars upside on it
and that's life-changing you know
there's genuinely an amount of money
that
through the best will in the world you
might have wanted to drive it
but like hit come on you can kind of see
how that happens to that I believe
that's basically why that happened
obviously values have softened but even
still they're a million dollars right a
million so there's still like four or
five hundred grand there was one that
was really interesting it had like 60
000 miles on it and this guy daily drove
it on his commute I think it was like 75
miles each way I was daily driving this
car and put it up on bring a trailer to
sell it and I think it hit 850 thousand
eight hundred thousand dollars didn't
sell didn't hit the reserve but still
the fact that someone's willing to pay
300 000 over MSRP 60 000 miles on it
daily driven like that uh goes to show
you and that car apparently had like
zero issues yeah all complicated modern
cars perform better if you drive them
lots like I'm a firm believer in like
modern stuff you know the latest
McLarens and especially hybrids the more
miles you can do on them the better but
not necessarily crazy crazy miles but
like regularly driven sure like don't
have to sit for six months without being
touched kind of thing
very different on slightly older stuff
they don't have all the electronic
Gremlins and things in the same way
seals and things like that still but
it's it's not the same
um and the 4GT is just the ultimate
example of a company making a car for a
reason you know that was a massive loss
leader for Ford they had this idea that
they wanted to go back to Lamar 50 years
after they won with the GT40 they wanted
to win it they did win it and they were
going to do that at whatever expense it
would take and there were loads of
discussions about the the balance of
performance and whether the car was
whether it was fair whether it had been
sandbagged in the build up or whatnot
but the fact remains that they did go
and win and that means that every car
they built has cost them some huge
amount of money you know it's not a car
that was introduced to police
shareholders to make
X profit on each unit Etc et cetera it's
a car that was introduced for an
emotional reason and I think that's
always been a link to values now when
cars have a reason behind them there's
always huge demand around them the
latest example of this is the amg-1
where they've put the Formula One engine
into the road car and it's the F1 engine
that's LED Mercedes to win eight
Constructors
um eight seven how many is it a few
Constructors Championship wins brain
block right at the second with with that
engine and again
massive cost to the company but if you
want one right now and they haven't even
built them yet you need to stump up a
million over already and what is it two
and a half million yeah I know yeah and
that's before cars are physical believe
me when the cars are physical it'll be
even more like it's crazy but it's a car
with a reason it seems like it's a lot
more common now that cars are a million
dollars is now the best price oh the car
Market's crazy you know if you think to
James's Bugatti Veyron when that car
came out if you wanted to spend a
million dollars on the car you had one
choice a Bugatti Veyron that was it that
was the creme de La Creme nothing else
if you want to spend a million dollars
on a car now you've got about 50 choices
it's crazy to think that that one
million dollar Flagship Benchmark I mean
Bugatti set the the standards themselves
because their most expensive car was a
one-off they created Noir which is one
of my most viewed videos as it happens
it's on 9 or 10 million or something so
again the first video in the world from
the reveal at the Geneva Motor Show
doing what I do
um that car cost in Euros it was 16.7
million oh my God so in the region of 20
million so the most expensive car in the
world 20 years ago was a million and now
it's 20 million that is the most
expensive car in the world new car it's
actually been superseded since by a
Rolls-Royce oh what is that the boat
yeah they made the sweptail and then the
three boat Tails Rolls Royce yes how
much well a regular production model is
a six figure sum this exactly this
specific boat tail they never confirmed
but it's believed to be in the 25 to 30
million dollar range what makes it so
special they made three of them
completely bespoke for the customer so
so not three so I think I think it's one
customer and two of his acquaintances
I'm not entirely sure but somebody
effectively went to Rolls-Royce and said
I would like to build a one-off car with
you I want to make one that's for me and
no one else and Rolls-Royce was just so
sure so that experience then for the
customers sitting with the designers to
work on it sitting with the material
Specialists sitting wherever with
everybody to be part of every step of
the process
I wonder how worth it it is for
Rolls-Royce to do that because like
you'd think they'd be making a ton more
money at just like 75 million dollars to
Rolls Royce doesn't sound like that
crazy of an amount right I actually
think it's probably quite significant I
mean I don't know what the actual cost
of the car is to make
but for that money you can hire quite a
few really skilled employees you can
really bring a lot to your company to
your team and there's got it let's face
it it's got to be 50 million dollars
profit in that or something probably
okay but there's also going to be a good
image for Rolls-Royce to have custom
one-off cars and to be the brand that
produces the most expensive car in the
world yes you know that really adds to
The Prestige of the brand so this guy
like basically hand selected exactly
what he wanted in this car and it is two
acquaintances get the exact same card
did they also get to hand select they're
all the same design but they're
different materials and done in slightly
different ways got it and what like kind
of like unique stuff do they have
because I remember Rolls Royce they used
to come out or they had this car that
like had you know the umbrella that pops
out of the door that was like the big
thing like a super long time ago or
whatever like what kind of unique
features now we're talking about the
umbrella
oh yes there the umbrella like seat
warmers
massaging seats we are talking custom
wooden teak decks on the rear back that
open up to reveal your crystal glass set
inside and your expensive Cutlery and
Crockery and whatever else all stored
within the back of the car and like to
have like a refrigerator or something
yeah you can have a refrigerator in any
more choice
all right so if you could think of it
they'll probably do it I heard a lot of
it is the type of wood but also like
diamond encrusted whatever you can get
do they have yeah let's start yeah
but they do that too no it's it's like
you say it's it's not even just the car
it's the fact that the wood will be some
super rare impossible to get wood that
is however old and whatever I'm not an
expert in that sphere
um and the same with every other
material you know the type of leather
that's used the materials for the switch
gear and
even the paint it will all be done with
things that no one else is going to do
because of the cost is crazy but I mean
let's let's be real if you're buying a
25 30 million dollar car you're probably
in billionaire status it's it's very
different at that level what can you do
that's different it's like all your
mates have 100 million dollar yachts and
private jets yeah whatever right oh I'm
going to own the most expensive
Rolls-Royce now what I like is the one
guy does the Pinstripes did you see this
video on this guy yeah yeah it's got to
be more than one guy now they're making
too many cars you think so it's
certainly for a long time has been one
guy it's been one guy yeah I found it so
interesting he said he never took a day
off because he was worried that if he
takes one day off he's not going to be
as precise and for those unaware of what
we're talking about here the Pinstripe
is hand painted maybe now it's more than
one guy but for a while it was one
person who knew how to do this pinstripe
and he does it in one swoop across the
car and you can only get it right once
and any mistake it's like I don't know
if something like the whole car has to
be scratched like not but they have to
repaint yeah
anyway this guide is a perfectly
straight line from the start to the back
and one swoop and his whole life
revolves around that one line what do
you think he does like like if he
sprains his wrist or something like that
sure he has insurance
on that he would have to have insurance
on his wrist wow yeah and I think it
wasn't I think he was trying to teach
his son how to do it or like he wanted
to pass on that skill or that's what
that's what it is with these cars right
it's an emotional reason you you dream
of a Rolls-Royce because of this because
of things like this that are just
bizarre but so cool
that's what creates this like you know
as a child it's like one one day maybe
yeah so what is the most expensive car
sale now that isn't a new car oh
probably the ferrariant
recently a vintage Mercedes sold for 140
million dollars
and that became the most expensive car
in the world it was sold from the
Mercedes-Benz classic collection from
their own Heritage Fleet
um it's called an ulenhout and it's kind
of
they literally took their grand prix F1
car at the time put a roof on it and
made it a road car prototype so we all
knew this if this car came for sale as
road cars go it would be a record sale
and they did an RM Sotheby's auction
held at uh in Germany
um only a year or less than a year ago
and it sold at that price outside of
that about half of that will get you a
Ferrari 250 GTO which is the kind of
go-to that everyone talk has talked
about in recent years but you've got to
wonder now this Prestige thing comes
back into play right will Ferrari try
and find a more expensive car that they
can sell to be the most expensive car in
the world again but it's all it's a
funny conversation because
the Bugatti Atlantic there were three of
them they're only two surviving one
zoned by Ralph Lauren and one's owned by
someone else if either of those were
sold it'd probably be more but you'll
never know because it will never be sold
and there are a few cars like that
Mercedes also own the car that's
Sterling Moss drove to the win at the
sorry at the minute media if that car
was ever sold again 250 300 who knows
because if you want
the most famous race car ever
you're probably not the only person who
wants it and there are a few very
wealthy people that will fight to fight
that one out
wow yeah it's really interesting all
right so uh so after this afternoon
all right every car we do a little side
dancing you should get a Model T an
original Ford Model yeah that would be
quite cool actually that would make
incredible content so I'm gonna run the
car would be kind of cool we've had
Zenvo Center for GT okay let's do the
marks the GT Black Series I've driven
here I have an SLS Black Series which
was the predecessor I have a C63 Black
Series I technically own an AMG GTR
Roadster which is the convertible kind
of one of the one I have here are the
Fords I have a Shelby GT500 Mustang
which I bought out here drove 12 000
miles in the US and have just imported
to the UK which is kind of cool because
you can't buy Shelby Mustangs in Europe
astons
um the first car I ever revealed on my
channel uh as the shimmy mobile which
all my cars have become named since
actually the audience named them that
and it's kind of stuck around
um was a V8 Vantage Roadster that was
the first time I kind of revealed the
car on the channel it was the first time
I ever filmed myself talking to the
camera was driving that car so the first
time I ever tried to do a review and
it's so awkward to watch back now and
then the same car was the first time I
ever did like a vloggy vlog series on a
road trip in 2011.
um I was so young and it's so awkward to
watch now but it's kind of where it
began so I sold it in 2012 but I managed
to buy it back last year managed to
track down the same car so I earned that
and I'd also bought another Vantage from
Factory which I'd been able to film also
with Aston Martin the build so I'd
signed on the chassis and signed on the
back of the headrest and that kind of
stuff so that's a vantage 88 and I also
own an Aston DBS the bond era DBS which
is just a cool car it's actually for
sale but it's a cool car I had my fix I
got to own it that was that was one of
the things
um where are we uh Lamborghini Huracan
sto which is like they're crazy in your
face and mine's pink and yellow which
makes it even more in your face I was
like if I'm gonna spec a Lamborghini I'm
just going to do it as crazy as I can
sure go wild with it
um I don't even know where I'm at now
thinking around my garage renaults I
have a exact matching spec car to the
first car I ever owned I actually owned
the first car I ever owned but it got
involved in an accident so it got
scrapped and became a cube of metal wow
but I managed to track down the cube of
metal in a scrap yard and I owned that
wow
I did how much did a cube of metal cost
125 pounds I think it was what do you do
with it I just have it I haven't done
anything with it it's just sitting I
make it into a table or something cut in
half and I'd make like a few tables or
something yeah that's absolutely the
kind of idea so I have a replica of it
and I also have a car that Renault made
back in the early 2000s which is called
the Clio V6 that not many people know
but they stuck at a V6 engine in the
back of the hatchback so it's a rear
driven manual mid-engined hatchback
which is bizarre and really cool they're
very quickly becoming
um hyper collectible and going up in
value
um so I got in there on the right time
for sure what else do we have I have a
show car
Formula One
car from 1997. it's show car chassis one
of the winning Williams F1 car from that
year and that was the last year Williams
actually won the World Championship with
Jack field nerve so to have the show car
is really cool it's currently in
restoration because it's been repainted
and re-liveried because nobody really
cared about these things back then and
now they're like oh my gosh this is epic
so that's just a showpiece to have in
the garage it's not it's not a running
car it's just just a show car
um Lotus
I don't currently own a Lotus but I'm
about to go no I have two lotuses in low
tide in my garage and I belong to a
friend
what about the Exige or the Elise didn't
you get that so I've got two releases
that belong to my friend so the very
final one ever and one of the very
earliest ones
and our number plates are first and
final it's amazing God is that the
orange one the orange one okay so that
one's a friend I'm about to take
delivery of in a mirror the new car yes
like literally the day I get home from
this trip I'm taking delivery off my
mirror so that's kind of cool I haven't
mentioned Ferraris two Ferraris yes f90
stradale which is actually kind of my
daily driver a daily driver 1000
horsepower Ferrari oh my gosh which is
values are crazy yeah but it's um it has
electric drive it can do the commute
from home to home to work shall we say
to my garage and back so
I'm just doing it while I can and then I
have the GDC fall or so which is the
four seat V12 Ferrari as well what do
you think the total value is of those
cars the total Fleet value in dollars
would be roughly I guess seven and a
half that kind of region
I feel like it's got it more given the
number of million dollar cars I guess
I'm going off my insured UK values sure
probably U.S values we would be more
like 10. yeah probably because the UK
Market is softer with
all sorts of economic reasons and
whatnot so we're talking in in that kind
of region
it's like everything insurance is
horrible insurance is a big number
especially because of the exposure of
the cars if you think about it I drive
loads of miles I have different people
driving them fully open discussions with
my insurers they're actually great like
they know exactly what I do with the
cars they've come to inspect my garage
they specced out security requirements
that's something people always ask me
like
as if we haven't planned it yeah I don't
show obviously all the security stuff
through the channel but there's so much
that we had to put in like the budget
just to install what they needed at the
stars what do they need to give us an
idea I mean the obvious of the things
like the alarms the sensors the bollards
the camera systems the backup systems
the multiple connections the
just endless list of stuff wow
um all fully monitored all with police
presence really nearby all with
everything
um you know the police have been to
visit so they know what to do and where
to go and how to access anything they've
got that all filed et cetera Etc it's
like a full-on
full-on list of things
so the insurance company I would say
that I use are actually pretty good to
me considering what I do with all the
cars but it is you know my my annual
spend on a on my car insurance is like
enough to buy my Aston DBS
for example like a hundred thousand
dollars uh oh my gosh but it's a
business experience yeah yeah not fully
um you know it's not like a 100
write-off but I can expense parts of it
so it's kind of yeah it's just part and
parcel so for a lot of these cars though
how much of it is a balance between
what's going to do well for business and
YouTube versus how much is your passion
of I want to buy this car yeah it's it's
really interesting you know because
a car has a longevity to it oh sorry I
should say a restricted lifespan to it
on YouTube you know once people have
seen something for three years they
don't care anymore you know there's not
gonna be any more interesting content to
come around that so for example some of
my older cars that I've owned for six or
seven years
if I was doing this purely for business
they would have been on the chopping
block ages ago you know they make no
sense to keep because they still pay to
ensure them to tax them to run them to
service them to maintain them you know
and it all adds up significantly whereas
let's say the income generated against
them is kind of gone but that's where
the personal side comes in one because
I'm a hoarder too because I just love
them you know the memories the
experiences and I think I said earlier
this is one of the things for me it's
like
if you ask me why why would I work hard
what's my like goal it's because I want
to own and enjoy these cars so being
lucky enough to do that I feel like what
would I what would be the benefit of
selling a car that has a personal
connection to me right now and I don't
need to release the capital you know
it's Equity but at some point in the
future I can if I need to and I believe
it's quite a good place to have funds
anyway sure at the end of the day I
think it's an interesting space and a
space obviously I know quite well so on
the one hand there are cars like that on
the other hand there are very much cars
that I've bought specifically for a
Content series you know I know when I
buy it I'm keeping it for a year or
something maybe it's a bit of a project
maybe it's to do it up maybe it's for a
specific trip or something or maybe
because I already know that there's a
successor model coming that it that will
replace it certainly that kind of thing
so there's a there's a variety there's
no one rule of thumb like I say the
Zenvo wouldn't make sense as a car for
specifically for the channel but then
when you balance the fact that it's
really cool to do that and there's
potentially some upside in the future as
well and you know if the company is
successful my car's going to be worth a
lot more than I paid for it also so
that's a like a fun element to throw
into it so being part of that hopeful
success for them
um you know something like something
like the lambo is actually quite funny I
bought the lambo thinking I've got to
have a Lambo on the channel you know
because I look at James with right
garage of Lambos I look at David Exotics
with everything they do and you know
Lambo has always been the key to success
on YouTube I knew way back when I when I
changed my first McLaren to the second I
knew then if I bought an Aventador it
would do better I knew that because that
was right at the time when people were
discovering they made flames and yeah
they're just YouTube Gold
um and it was actually the Dubai Police
video I mentioned hadn't had their event
door as the thumbnail it's one of the
reasons why it did so well right
um
so I had known that but it wasn't really
me you know I didn't want my only
Supercar to be a Lambo I'm not that in
your face guy to try that kind of thing
um I'm more into the technical side of
you know the McLaren more about the
driving Dynamics than the flare
um but I figured it was it was time you
know I've owned cars I've been lucky to
own cars from everyone else
um in the Supercar space
um exception being Rolls-Royce and
Bentley because I'm saving that kind of
luxury car for gonna have something to
look forward to
um so I was like I'll try I'll order a
Lambo and you know make a whole series
around it but I tell you what I really
enjoyed it I really liked it I actually
put it up for sale because needs Master
had to had to clear some funds um for a
few other projects and things
and it's still advertised for sale at
this point in time no one's bought it
but I think I'm gonna take it back I
want it back yeah well it's still mine
so I can right right yeah um it's one of
those like I won't be unhappy if it
doesn't sell sure what's your team look
like by the way to maintain that I
imagine that's got to be someone's full
time maybe yeah completely completely
oil changes oh it takes time I mean I've
come here from being with James in Utah
yeah and he's managing his 15 odd cars
himself and I'm like you're crazy this
is this is too difficult when I got to
about I think around 12 cars was where I
was like I can't do this because one
stuff goes wrong with them but two every
car needs a service every year probably
needs a dealer visit for something else
every year and then you've got to deal
with all the paperwork and documents and
checking over and making sure
everything's right and it's if you're
living a busy schedule running a
business and you know on the go every
five seconds you can't do that so back
at home I have two guys employed
effectively at my garage which we call
the museum and they actually make videos
behind the scenes of the garage which is
quite fun as well
um and actually it's a completely
different type of content but the
audience have loved it which is which is
amazing
um outside of that
um a couple of people working full-time
on the like business side you know brand
Partnerships setting up the shoots and
opportunities because I'm filming nearly
every day um my partner travels with me
so we film all the videos together which
is quite fun and ran it manage all of
the short form content and social media
so we kind of include like all the
full-time people plus a couple of
part-time helping run my Facebook page
and that kind of stuff it's about 10
people around the whole operation wow
which people don't realize yeah people
think you just flip up a camera and
start filming and that's your video
that's done
um but I think anything like this and
you know within the next couple of weeks
my main channel is going to hit a
billion views which is quite fun
congratulations thank you I'm super
excited about it with anything that's
kind of at that scale
there's a whole lot more that goes into
it right it's not just I mean you know
with your operation and everything to
manage multiple channels and multiple
outlets and creating all sorts of
different types of content to go in
different places somebody might just see
like your main Channel and that's all
they see and they don't realize around
that you're actually uploading something
else every single day on other places
and it's not it takes serious amounts of
time and organization and structure to
do it I'll be out filming I've just got
off a plane I'm something hot and I'll
forget half the things I have to do so
if I don't have people around to kind of
support the operation it's not going to
happen can you talk about your income as
a percentage let's say you can like draw
up high what you know how big are each
slice as percentages ah it's very hard
to say because it fluctuates a lot
um you know this this time of year at
the end of the year you know lead up to
Christmas obviously ad revenues are
really high because companies are
promoting in a big way
um let's say the xiaomi 150 Network it's
probably roughly a third is
social media so not just YouTube it used
to be YouTube but now Facebook and
everything else has taken off in a big
way the third is brand deals brand
Partnerships and a third is probably
other things which could be affiliate
type things merch just all sorts of
other stuff that comes up you know
appearance fees or posting fees or
licensing or who knows what
random question but what is the worst
thing that's happened to you while
driving a car like have you ever been
driving like a super fancy car and then
I don't know something get gets kicked
up and criminals a truck drove into me
when I was driving my Center that was
pretty bad it hit you yeah that was
pretty bad so that makes it sound way
more dramatic than it was I'm sorry it
was completely fine and it wasn't too
bad it was just a very big bill
um I was driving down to one of the
biggest events of the year which is the
Goodwood Festival of speed held in the
UK so that's for me an absolute must
event it's equivalent to Monterey car
week and Pebble Beach that happens over
here
um and the car was due to be on show so
it was due to the on a stand that
evening I was driving it down just
picked it up sitting in traffic so I'm
going at 15 miles per hour no joke 15
miles an hour I'm in the exit Lane to
take my exit off the highway obviously
left side for the UK and I just get a
massive Bang from my right shoulder and
a Truck in the adjacent Lane I believe
had been flashed out by the car behind
me so he was late to take the slip Road
the slip lane and the car behind had
kind of backed off and flashed and he
just hadn't seen me there and he pulled
pulled straight into the back of the
center which damage wise was
vastly more Visual and it was mechanical
it was just body panels so no damage to
the suspension or to the like mechanic
side of it at all but I can tell you A
Center door Wing spoiler wheel and those
kind of cosmetic parts are very
expensive the repair bill on their
insurance was enough to buy would have
been enough to buy another like Flagship
McLaren car like a super City what would
you have done if they didn't have the
proper insurance
so in the UK you have to okay it works
quite quite differently
um even up to that value because here in
the US
the value of let's say a lot of people
would have the minimum of let's say 25
50 Grand yeah you would have to sue them
personally but they wouldn't have the
money no they wouldn't
um so in the UK all policies are I don't
know if they're unlimited but there's
certainly tens of millions so you're
kind of covered every policy it's
probably a government-backed type type
system I'm not entirely sure maybe it's
like all the insurance companies work
together but we have vastly more camera
control for this kind of things
so these kind of things so every police
car has what's called an anpr system
automatic number plate recognition so if
an ampr system flags a number plate
without insurance the person gets pulled
over immediately like every cop car
would have that so you can't really go
very many places without getting
anything pulled over
um so insurance is much more strictly
monitored here it's obviously a bit more
of a problem and just out of curiosity
what happened after that accident was
that guy just like freaking out because
I can imagine like a phone call with the
insurance company or so he's driving a
big rig and obviously his his company
policy was basically he's not allowed to
talk about it so we weren't allowed to
talk he wasn't allowed to talk about it
so it was really frustrating it took 21
months to get it settled oh my God and
it was like a week before I started my
Ford GT trip in the US so I was dealing
with this in the US with the time zones
so every morning I would wake up two
hours earlier than I needed to because I
had to spend two hours on the phone call
to lawyers and stuff it was an absolute
nightmare
and what was your immediate feeling
afterwards like so do you know what do
you know so obviously immensely stressed
but my biggest feeling this is really
really weird I was supposed to be
driving the Ford GT but we were running
behind schedule and I just put the Ford
GT in a truck
um because oh no sorry the truck that
was due to take it had had due to take
the senate had left which is why I was
driving the center I was supposed to be
driving the GT and I was going to come
back and get it later
um but obviously a week before my 4GT
trip to the US so I've already booked
the plane airfare for the cargo I've
already paid for it all I've already
booked the whole thing so my my first
thing on my day was thank goodness it
wasn't the GT partly because the center
is an easier car to repair than the GT
because the factory is around the corner
this actually happened about 10 miles
from the factory no joke like it it I
was I was thinking at the time you know
if this happens at the GT which I know
every car has its own kind of unique
body panels you can't just get a new
bumper and put it on it doesn't
necessarily fit so perfectly
plus the fact that if it needs to get
fixed it has to go to Canada
which is also a little bit of a problem
even though I guess it was booked a
flight to New York but that's
either here or there so I was definitely
thinking thank goodness my GT trip isn't
ruined and what about the display
afterwards so I put the GT on the stand
instead so obviously very lucky to have
the option to do that and to have to
have these kind of cars and to know the
right connections to help with all the
logistics and I think
being a car YouTuber it had been on my
mind for a long time before if I ever
get involved in an accident what's the
procedure you know what's the what what
do I have to do because obviously the
public are going to know about it this
is at the side of the UK's busiest
Motorway in a traffic jam everybody knew
about it straight away while I was at
the side of the road probably five
different people I knew drove past me
like it was everybody knew about it and
I think a bit of
you just have to stay
calm and have to like think about what's
happened and what you do you know
firstly everyone's okay it wasn't a high
speed impact at all obviously so no no
drama no airbags nothing like that
second thing is right I need to explain
this because if I don't explain it
people are going to run away with
all sorts of rumors and stories and
things so I did make a video on the day
straight away
um and I think that's you know that was
the right thing to do not blaming
anybody not you know it's just it
happened
it's not too bad we're all fine
let's see what happens down the line
with this because you know you could
make a video kicking and screaming and
being like ah my God I can't believe
this idiot drove into me Etc et cetera
but what do you gain from that you know
at the end of the day firstly it's a car
could be fixed nobody's hurt that's the
most important thing but equally you're
in a State of Shock you don't you don't
really know you haven't processed it all
yet you know I'm like I'm never that was
the first time I'd been involved in a
road accident so it's a I mean I say
accidents obviously it's I could still
drive home it's not like it's
or whatnot but it was the first time
taking that in and especially what it
would happen to my most expensive car
right the center cost more although
worth less than a GT it did cost more to
buy
um so I would say that was like
just super intense thinking about
everything because there were the
different elements of it there was the
getting the car to the show stand that I
promised and committed to there was the
I need to explain this somehow and then
there's the I'm already dealing with the
logistics because I've got to get
multiple cards down to this event
tonight which starts tomorrow morning
so put all that together and yeah it was
a challenge and what about just like any
other random thing that could
potentially happen to you while you're
on the road for example I was just
recently driving a bit ago and a massive
cardboard box hit this semi truck right
in front of me and flew over and it was
flying on the freeway and I was driving
my car and I was like oh my gosh and I
like swerved out and I swear this seems
like a homing missile like it went this
way I'm like no no no I swear this way
it flies because what happened in slow
motion and then this massive box just
hits the front of my car and I look and
there's like some scratches and stuff
like that but stuff like that just
happens and whether or not you have
control over it like sometimes sometimes
you don't right yeah I mean the car I
have here has a small crack on the front
splitter which happened because I hit a
tire that was on the road like a truck
tire that had just been left in the
middle of the highway
like at driving at night didn't see it
that doesn't necessarily worry you too
much you're still just like you know I'm
still gonna drive these cars I'm gonna
enjoy these cars yeah so the closest to
near disaster we came was actually when
I was filming with uh another friend in
the YouTube world uh life of Palace
Aaron Palos we were filming together in
Colorado and we were driving on the
highway in his Ferrari FF
um followed by my partner driving in my
GT500 and there was a um a ladder on the
highway there was a ladder across our
lane like no joke full-on like
extendable kind of if you drove over
that that would have destroyed the car
because that would have been front under
trees everything
um thankfully we we avoided it but that
was definitely a moment we were like
whoa that could have gone wrong do you
know what I've been very lucky that
there haven't been too many
disasters like bad things I mean I've
had more than enough flat tires or ran
out of fuel because there are no gas
stations anywhere or you know like stuff
that almost is just kind of it just
Fades into it you don't remember it
because it doesn't really stand out I
think the things that stood out to me
like the random really cool stuff that's
happened you know they're just
People You Meet along the way or places
I've ended up and that kind of thing
what about speeding tickets I'm pretty
good with speeding really it's yeah no
speeding tickets never had any points on
my license really in the UK okay
um I've had a couple of the like tiny
ones I I don't think I've ever had a
speeding ticket in the U.S I've probably
driven
in the US in total I would guess
probably somewhere 50 60 70 000 miles
I've never had a speeding ticket in the
US as fast as you've ever gone in a car
oh very fast how fast oh you could stay
on the track right no no I drive in
Germany all the time I used to have a
place in Germany oh yeah the Autobahn so
the car I've got outside has been 205
miles an hour it was 105. does it not
scare you oh it's completely legal it's
fine I know but I'm not saying it there
but just like your life like if anything
were to happen at that speed it's like
what's the thing I should stress and
perhaps I say I've been 202 like just
just throwing it out there it's that
before you do that like you're getting a
car looked over you know you're doing it
right you're not just jumping into
someone else's car that you don't know
and keeping your foot pinned at 205. I
think when you drive frequently I mean
I've probably driven 50 different cars
over 200 miles an hour so I've got quite
a lot of high-speed Driving Experience
and you know you're not going to go
flying past a car that's going 70 at 200
like that's stupid so you're doing a
wide open road yeah so you'll you'll
you'll only go that speed if you're on a
straight section with distance you can
see to be clear you know on a Sunday
morning you're not going to be doing
that on
a Friday afternoon right on a busy bit
of Autobahn
um
you know it's it's a it's actually a
very delicate Topic in Germany because
there are constantly things where people
have driven their cars to top speed and
it perhaps hasn't been as safe as it is
and you know you shouldn't obviously
technically you shouldn't glorify the
speed of it but it is legal to do so if
conditions allow
um
I think it's it's one that probably
won't be around forever though they're
not gonna allow that to stick around
aren't there many accidents on the
Autobahn or is it relatively safe it's
actually relatively safe because the
lane etiquette of German drivers is
unbelievably good like no joke people
will always look in their mirror before
they move over people will always tuck
back to the right after they've passed
like it's really good
um I've never there's nowhere else in
the world where people
follow the the highway code as well as
they do I think Automotive is instilled
in the blood from the beginning they
grow up in the country with the Autobahn
so if you know there's a chance that
when you're going it you know the
equivalence of 70 miles an hour it's
obviously in kilometers in Germany you
know there's a chance that a car is
going to come up behind you at 150
because you know all the German cars are
or the majority of German cars are
electronically limited to 155 which is
250 kilometers an hour so everybody
knows that if they're driving at 120
there could be an E-class or an
Audi A8 or something that just comes
flying up behind them at 250 kilometers
an hour 155. I think if you know that
from a young age
you're very conscious then that when you
start driving
it's just part of it you're always going
to look in your mirror also if you are
going like I don't know 90 plus 100 or
so miles an hour you probably are more
scared to like get distracted by your
phone or to like not be a super oh yeah
absolutely right whereas if you're going
like 65 or like 50 you know what I mean
you're probably like yeah it's not a big
deal if I I don't know the exact figures
but I wouldn't be surprised if even the
German you know accident rate per
X miles or kilometers is probably even
better than many countries you would be
surprised by obviously if there is an
accident at high speed it can get very
very messy very quickly but the
accidents aren't that frequent
yeah I think most people most people
aren't stupid right most people know
that driving 200 is not a good idea if
you're not ready I feel like you're in
the US people are that stupid though
unfortunately some will be but some will
be everywhere yeah I think Germans are
very sensible overall sure so what is
your thought now on the car market today
car Market's really interesting isn't it
I mean I know you've talked a bit about
a lot of people are probably going to go
upside down on car loans you know values
have been very high in the last year or
two mostly because of shortage of
manufacturing people basically were
sitting on money grants loans whatever
and didn't really know what to do so
people have been out buying and now
there's a ramp up more in production
more cars hit the market
value is going to come down can kind of
only go one way which has already
started
um you know if you look at the the top
end of the market it's not really
affected you know people who can buy
multi-million dollar cars can still buy
multi-million little cars they might
there might be some who need to get
funds out to keep their business alive
or something like that and there was a
lot of that in the pandemic you know
fire sale of different cars for people
to keep their businesses live which is
respectable I think
um I worry about it much more in the
world where people are financed into
something beyond their means and this
will heavily hit the 100 to 200 000 car
market where people who are you know
like I have been in the past
financed into something with very little
room to spare because they wanted to
because they could and I know this is
the industry I know best which isn't
obviously the the mass complete Globe
for many respect but it's the world I
spend most of my time around and the
markets will move very slowly and
eventually prices are just going to come
down and down and down and down and down
and there'll be a lot of people who need
to pay money to get out of their loans
this is going that way completely yeah
what do you think about the hyper cars
the cars 500 000 to a million
I think yeah I think I think if we say
500 000 up I think really the global
market for people who buy those kind of
cars is actually not shrinking in the
slightest you know a lot of people have
made a lot of money in recent years
um I mean it was actually fascinating
how many people
specifically through crypto made a lot
of money very quickly
um the auction Market in the last two
years has been fascinating because a lot
of cars have been bought by people
who've made Millions overnight and just
want whatever car they want right so
they just buy it I think if you if you
have a big crypto portfolio and you're
used to watching it going up by a six
figure up and down by a six figure or
seven figure sum every five minutes
you kind of lose some of the sense of
let's say appreciation of the value that
a traditional collector might have yeah
you know so all of a sudden that car
that should have been one and a half
million that's two million whatever
right they just buy it lots of those
cars are actually Now quickly coming
back to the market and no unsurprisingly
um
I think generally speaking though that
demand is just going to go up the
combination of the fact that no new car
really does what all the cars do you
know they don't have that same
passion and involvement because it's all
Tech it's all electric you know there
are some fantastic electric cars that
are arriving now like the performance
figures are mind-blowing and what they
can do is mind-blowing
but let's face it no one needs a one
million two million three million dollar
car like there's no need for that the
reason you buy that is because your
heart says I want that and if you want
that you generally want an emotional
connection with it now whether that's
because you've always dreamed of owning
a Ferrari or whether that's because you
want to feel a vibrating engine you know
the rawness of the revs as they get up
towards the top and you pull a paddle or
engage the next gear or whatever it is
so I think that end of the market as
we're seeing really if you look at cars
like the f40s and f50s you know those
really Prestige names both manufacturers
and the models those are very solid
Investments
um you know my my favorite car my dream
car is a Ferrari F50 that was my first
poster car they came out in the mid 90s
I was you know seven years old eight
years old whatever it was
um
they were
Pride I don't know exactly but four or
five hundred thousand dollars not very
long ago and now a good one is six
million yeah that's the car that's like
it was completely out of reach 10 years
ago 500k couldn't have dreamed of that
and now it's at six million it's
completely out of reach I can't dream of
that is there any car now that that you
feel like is the next one for you to get
like I would think a career GT free it
would be like that so Carrera GT is a
really softly priced in the UK versus
here here they've started hitting a
couple of million which to me is crazy
yeah yeah it's crazy crazy
um good chunk under that for a UK car I
mean for sure that's like a dream but
again there was a time when I was
offered a Carrera GT for 220 000 pounds
I remember it well so the idea of paying
nearly a million now is still like oh I
could have bought that for 80 less you
know what about like a Lexus LFA again
another car I would love but same story
I was offered one for 200 000 Euros you
remember when no one was buying this
yeah they were sitting on Lots on sold
you could get money off
it's the same problem for me um I was
super lucky to buy my SLS Black Series
um I actually bought it
at the time February 2020. I bought the
car you can imagine the weeks that
followed that I was like what have I
done the world's about to fall apart
spending buying a car if that value
outright was not a good idea at that
particular time
luckily I guess for me whether that
storm
um had to make quite a few Cuts during
2020 and things but come out the other
side of it and those cars are now it's
worth at least 2x what I bought bought
it for so I'm very happy about that on
the other side but certainly there was a
period of like whoa whereas if I didn't
already own one
I'd be looking at the market now and
saying it's gone that ship sailed
I think I'm too much of a
I'm too calculating in the sense of I
could have done that sure and I'm not
you know I get as I think anybody who's
in the public sphere who people think
they can make a quick Buck out of does I
get plenty of people offering me stuff I
don't really want for massively inflated
Figures it's like I didn't get here by
making unwise decisions I think that's
the same with cars you know I I enjoy
the fact that I'm lucky to drive so many
of these all the time through my videos
you know if I would like to drive a
Carrera GT or an F50 it's probably just
a phone call away
and that's a crazy physician to be in
and I can't you know I can't believe
I can say that but truly thankful that
it's the case just I couldn't justify
doing it I get that yeah where are you
investing today is it all in the cars or
are you buying real estate so stocks I'm
very heavily in the cars obviously yeah
too many eggs in one basket in any
realistic normal world but I think my
justification for it is that this is my
life you know this is the life I live is
making the videos and being invested in
cars means that I have more avenues for
content and I just enjoy making the
videos so it's kind of
maybe that's my man math sales pitch to
myself sure
um I've put in small investments into
some different things obviously have
some money in the stock markets never
really did the crypto thing started in
crypto in the early days I bought some
Bitcoin when it was like ten dollars no
yeah but I sold it when it was 100. uh
because I was like I've done quite well
okay next yeah yeah I'm out it's peaked
yeah well that was yeah I think 2012
maybe about that kind of time wow how
did you find Bitcoin at ten dollars I
don't really know to be honest I think a
friend must have mentioned it
I I really couldn't tell you
um
but I I was I was more having fun
playing the quick ups and downs rather
than kind of buying and holding I just
had a little bit of in and out but like
I say once it got to that figure and
then you know I watched it all go up and
say oh I should have stuck with that I
should have stuck with things and Tesla
and should have stuck with everything
but shouldn't we all
um at certain points
um but I haven't really gone into the
real estate thing partly because you you
got to think this is another difference
in markets and locations
um UK property at the time I could have
got in and started things you know let's
say six seven years ago hasn't really
increased since
[Music]
um certainly not quite the same growth
and demand as you see in like Southern
Florida or here in Vegas for example
it's
it's quite
it's quite different so I have no
regrets about that up to this point I
mean they'll become a time and you know
I'd love to build myself a nice house or
something sure some inspiration from
some friends of doing that right
um I think I'm I'm more on the road with
all my videos travel a lot
um and quite enjoy my current setup I
rent an apartment in London it works
works quite well so I'm gonna stick with
that now speaking of Bitcoin I had an
interesting experience I had a body when
I was probably 21 I was really into the
tech scene and he first introduced me to
bitcoin when it was a dollar and he was
showing me all the cool stuff on the
Silk Road and not like cool stuff isn't
like a higher Hitman or something like
that but he was showing me like you have
to like just just the intricacies of
like what's involved in that and I just
found it so cool that like oh you have
to do this and I remember him telling me
Bitcoin like everything was done with
Bitcoin and I remember thinking oh is
this a Bitcoin a dollar he's like no
they just happened to be trading at the
same same level so that was like my
first intro to bitcoin back then but he
took me to some sort of
I don't know if it was a conference or
some sort of like his work Tech event
and there was a dude there who was going
up to everybody handing out these cards
and he came up as like I'm just trying
to promote Bitcoin and there's a wallet
address on here and there's like a
Bitcoin on it there's something like
that and I remember thinking oh that's
cool and I put in my pocket and I went
home and maybe like a few weeks later I
took it out and I like typed in because
it wanted to go to this website like
type in the address and I typed in the
address and I remember thinking like I
think it was either half a Bitcoin or a
Bitcoin that was on there but I remember
seeing the value of it as being like two
three dollars or something worth it I
was like what am I gonna do with this
and I just left it there and I kept that
car for years in a drawer and when
Bitcoin hit it must have been like 50 or
60 000 like I should go to that card I
gotta find it yeah and I looked through
everywhere I threw it out yeah could not
find it so Somewhere Out There is one of
those cards and then I looked it up
online to see if other people were
getting the same cards and sure enough
there were maybe about a dozen people
doing this
handing out these cards is because
they're excited to like share the
message of Bitcoin back then yeah and I
found cards that looked very similar to
the one that I received and it was like
this kind of holographic credit card
looking thing
but yeah so it's out there I threw it
away so in some dump somewhere as a
Bitcoin maybe half of one my brother has
a very similar story really bought a big
bought one BTC for I think I can't
remember maybe it was 100 200 that kind
of region and on his laptop obviously
moved to another laptop by the time it
got to a lot of money went back to his
old laptop couldn't turn it on hard
drives bricks itself and it's kind of
like what can I do to get this back yeah
nope what I find interesting and I think
this is going to come way in the future
of Bitcoin just depending on what
happens but how many Bitcoins are out
there that are just inaccessible yeah if
there's 21 million Bitcoins what
percentage of them are just straight up
never going to enter circulation because
they were lost every day probably a few
more than before right so I'm curious
the true number of real Bitcoins or
rather is it 15 million is it gonna be
14 million it's not 21. well
a lot of the early miners or
Distributors will have had much larger
quantities that they can't get into now
right so anybody who's acquired Bitcoin
in recent years presumably still has it
or knows the value of it yes whereas it
was so much easier to get
no nearly 10 years ago but probably
harder to still have an interesting
question it would be we'll find out one
day yeah uh my last question for you how
do you post a video a day how have you
done that for 13 I didn't realize it's
every day yeah
um across all the channels it's
literally been a video every day
um the only year I went every single day
without fail was 2017. uploaded on my
main Channel every single day of the
calendar year and it was intense at the
end of the year it was kind of I need a
break
um I think just because I enjoy it so
much you know we get to do so much cool
stuff drive so many incredible cars
opportunities that really pinched me
pinch myself moments all the time
um and I enjoy every factor of it I
enjoy both the cars the filming the
travel so the things that would normally
put somebody off from doing that because
they need a break from their job or from
their work isn't an issue for me you
know I I long believe that you know if
you love what you do you never work a
day in your life I think I'm lucky to be
in that space
um you know there's a ton of hard work
boring stuff accounts booking things
travel plans etc etc but
the highlights are so cool and I try and
be quite efficient with the way I film
you know I've obviously evolved over
time the techniques behind it there's
very little redundant footage it's very
much filmed in a way that I know how
it's going to be edited or how I'm going
to edit because I edit most of the
content still myself as well let's
capitalize on what I'm good at which is
knowing details about cars you know
create the content in that way or if I'm
out of my element rather than struggling
through invite somebody into the video
who does know what we're talking about
in that specific model or you know
somebody from the brand or somebody from
The Collector themselves or that kind of
thing
um to make it all quite smooth and try
and just shoot it in a way that
it's actually not as time consuming as
people think you know for me like a good
video is one that I film within an hour
or two and takes 10 minutes to edit sure
then I've done it right you know it
still does tons of views not happens
very well I don't have a video idea that
day but you're like I just gotta post
something it's a very planned ahead I'm
I'm super on it with my schedules and
agendas so a complete travel itinerary
that my whole team has access to
it's quite a manual document to be
honest but you know every line is a day
here's the video I'm filming here's
where I'm gonna be here's the travel I'm
doing here's the Google Maps root link
here's the booking references is
everything and then a separate document
which is what's going live on each
channel on each platform every day so
color coded so if I'm stuck for an idea
it's red if I've got the idea but it's
not filmed yet it's orange if I filmed
it it's yellow if it's good to go live
it's green so it's super visual you just
load it up you can see instantly oh my
gosh in three days there's a problem
Q brainstorming
yeah so it's wow there's a lot of very
cool planning behind the scenes which
definitely comes from working in finance
you know spreadsheets and nothing like
on that details definitely from the work
background that's cool do you have
anything Jack anything else
I don't think so uh yeah I did ask I did
ask overrated cars what's an underrated
car
oh
underrated cars I like that
underrated
[Laughter]
Acura NSX for me second generation so
not the like so the new hybrid One
latest the latest one I actually agree I
quite like them I do quite like them
um most people find them a bit I I think
probably quite a few new cars are
underrated especially by petrol heads
because they don't have the the noise of
older cars but technology
technologically can be significantly
obviously more advanced you know things
like hybrids you still got a combustion
engine that sounds great but you can
experience that Tech as well
um trying to think of something a little
bit older that would be
quite underrated
or undervalued or something
there are so many I mean I've got a
short list of cars more from my
childhood that I'm really looking to to
add to my collection just like a you
know a random car that you really
appreciate a car I like and I would but
the thing is anything I say now the
value no I'm sorry you gotta buy it
first yeah I gotta buy it first wait to
post until you buy the car and now
you're good
um a car I'm really after at the moment
actually that I'd like to find one of is
a BMW 1M
which is what that is one Series Coupe
manual gearbox limited edition kind of
last hurray that they made of it and I
think that's a very interesting era so
this is 2011.
um because this is an era
if you think the way the car market or
the limited edition or Supercar Market
moves is often in generational phases so
when people who had those cars on their
posters when they're a teenager get into
the position to have some money they go
and buy them so you see cars becoming
valuable about 20 years after they
existed or introduced it's it's if you
look through time it's actually quite
cyclical like that
um so I think a lot of cars from the
early 2000s that perhaps haven't been
appreciated in recent years are about to
be appreciated a whole lot more
if you could have one car in the entire
world that's ever existed okay but you
can't sell it yeah get it for free and
you can't make any content around it nor
bring it to meats and get like external
benefit by networking and driving just
owning just driving privately at 50.
easy yeah it's easy for me because the
f50s and all the cars 25 years old would
never be great for videos videos always
like new stuff I think older just
doesn't work so well whereas the F50 for
me I'd just go and drive every morning
and be a very happy bunny well he's cool
I haven't driven that many cars to
really give a good answer that's the
honest truth I mean I loved the model 3
Tesla is like a daily driver but the
favorite card that I've ever owned was
probably the uh Lotus Elise
it's the most fun I was thinking you
might pick a Ford GT no you know what
something about the Lotus of just
feeling like really tight and secure
within the car and like have it be
really Nimble and like you could see
everything around you and Tiny and
practical uncomfortable
yeah the 4GT I like the car but I'm
terrified to drive it I feel like it's
very wide I'm always paranoid I'm gonna
go over like one of those bumps when I'm
parking yeah you know like little speed
things
um I'm just paranoid something's gonna
happen the Lotus Elise was something I
never had to worry about it yeah that's
true you don't have to worry about
getting your head chopped off either
yeah or that for GT problems yeah
I I'm I'm good I'm Not Too Tall so like
I never have to yeah well I'm telling
every passenger who gets every passenger
I do yeah and it's but even for me I
know like I have you know a few inches
but like you're still scared it's like
the because it's a metal blade you're
pulling towards your head yeah
thank you I really appreciate it uh make
sure to get your free stock at public
you'll be linked in the description
until next time thanks man